the lines that I really really liked as
white I'm frankly I'm unfamiliar with
this position this is uh they're playing
it with Bishop F5 and they're getting
these uh strange lines just having a
look at the statistics on the day and
the opening database it wasn't it wasn't
it's not really a surprise why you're
unfamiliar with this type of position
because there were very few games in the
database I mean you're looking at a
handful at the most and I think they've
already branched off into novelty
territory Christian that that's right
and if you remember that game I think it
was named Silver versus startev right
earlier in the event and we were
discussing this type of position because
they did play a very similar situation
as well Bishop to F5 is by far the best
move in the position is not the most
played move in the position Bishop to E7
and Visually it makes the most sense to
go for Bishop E7 and go for Castle and
things of that nature the problem with
Bishop to E7 is that it immediately
allows this move a D4 and you don't have
a time to bring the setup to the defense
of the Knight on e4 so for example you
go C5 Bishop to D3 and now I'm sort of
forcing you to take on C3 and I played
D4 in one move keep that in mind
for example after Bishop to F5 the main
line is D3 and after D3 take on C3 take
on C3 C5 or Bishop to E7 and now White's
main option is to play once again D4 but
you spend two tempies to get to this
position so obviously this is an
improved version for uh black this one
is quite an important distinction in
this particular variation and after
Bishop to F5 he decided not to go for D3
it's all about this one tempo right I
want to meet whenever you're going to go
C5 with D4 in one move that's why he
waited he played this waiting move
Bishop to E2 if you do play the move C5
then I can have ideas of D4 challenged
upon on C5 in one go so this is a very
very important distinction D4 was
levon's Choice Knight takes E4 Bishop
takes E4 and we have a D3 in the
position Bishop to C4 get this bishop
out first and after that only play the
move a D3 is the main line but looking
at the engine D3 is the proposed moves
this is how this players train right
they take these Sidelines and they go
deep as deep as they can with the engine
with the help of their seconds as well
and they find wrinkles in the position
very very distinctive wrinkles and this
is exactly what we're seeing but we also
know Levon plays this with the white
pieces as well he's a well-established
English player C4 he loves it we've seen
how powerful his opening preparation is
in last year's event as well I'm
reminding myself of this match between
himself and Ray Robson and Rey somehow
tried to play the move C4 in fact
himself with the white pieces he got
demolished he got demolished I think
Levon finished with more time than he
actually started with so he's a very
very proficient player when it comes to
this type of imbalance structures
imbalance positions and he knows his
theory as well so let's find doubt what
Fabiano prepared at home and let's find
out how Levon will answer to those
challenges well after Castle's Knight C6
Bishop came to F4 and that's actually a
novelty on our uh screen we've actually
seen a2a3 in the past with the idea of
B4 but Bishop F4 and that was a game
between topalov and Hikaru Nakamura in
2017. by the way A3 is not the best move
Bishop to F4 seems to be the computer's
uh Top Choice as well H6 and now the
question is is black actually preparing
to go G5 perhaps G5 yes he is and that's
why he played this move Bishop to G3
right because now after G5 I can stop
you from playing G4 with the move H3 so
the position well perhaps you weaken
your oppon structure a bit too much on
the king side he decided against it he
actually no he just played G5 he just
played G5 it's on the board right now
right the computer doesn't like it the
computer really doesn't like this move
G5 but it is
he knows what he's doing so perhaps this
is the right direction Knight to E2
seems to be the best way now that you
don't have enough attackers on the pawn
on E5 to be able to capture it
immediately and I'm getting ready to
blast open the king side with the move
F4 that's why I played this move Knight
to D2 followed by F4 potentially try to
weaken the king side my guess is that
black is going to try to Castle
alongside absolutely we're going to have
to wait and see these players are
speeding towards some sort of position
that they both seem to be aware of what
they need to do in and uh yeah this this
is going to be a big fight yeah I agree
great stuff I mean who's better prepared
I mean because G H6 G5 is is definitely
throwing down the gauntlet that's a
challenging uh approach by Lavon with
the black pieces in the first one not
not not warming up but just immediately
I've noticed that about lavon's games in
these last few years especially when it
comes to these rapid time controls and
Blitz time control he's not afraid to
play in a very creative way and somehow
you get the touch that you know he's
perhaps looked to this position but
maybe it's kind of more divine
inspiration some freestyling going on
and saying to the opponent hey you know
right I I'm gonna play confidently I'm
gonna play quickly and I roughly know
what to do with my pieces it's not only
that but he's enjoying himself in the
past few tournaments and I've been
talking to him as well over dinners
breakfast in tata steel we were staying
at the same hotel and he was saying that
look they pay me to do something that I
would do regardless so how can I not
enjoy what I'm doing and how can I not
enjoy playing chess and playing this
type of creative moves on the board he's
enjoying himself and whenever Levon is
enjoying himself he's a dangerous man I
can tell you that wonderful I've got to
ask the question after the move G5 can I
play Queen four oh you can definitely do
queen A4 and but how are you going to
respond to H5
I was hoping it wasn't uh an issue over
there so I'm thinking Queen A4 you're
thinking H5 let's go wow okay so
understand H4 right probably you have to
respond with H4 H4 and then after G4 I'm
guessing and now you're uh borderline
lost I will take on H4 I'm borderline
lost yes you've got very precise to
survive this one really wow this 1
D5 is a force of nature in the position
look at it like this Knight takes H4 I
go Bishop to E7 and you're very happy
because you get your knight to F5 close
to my king you get a check on G7 very
disruptive right H4 forget about it H4
followed by H3 and once this long
diagonal opens up and you're going to
have to open it up by force almost after
the move H3 also I can try to go to G8
Target The Pawn on G2 first and then go
to H3 this one is not looking I mean
look at this yeah my king is we have to
show it right I have to show the
Checkmate in the position H3 you try to
sidestep that with G3 and H2 a checkmate
with a pawn so you you don't see that
very often in so H5 is actually a very
serious threat especially when I'm
moving my queen away so between A4 is a
bad move yeah probably remarkable as
Christian has highlighted you need to
resolve the tension
92.92 maybe can you go Bishop F3 because
you've been kind of like banging on
about how wonderful this lovely Bishop
on D5 is why not trade it off yeah
Bishop 3 is also an idea but once again
Knight D2 stops the move H5 at least
momentarily uh and and that's quite
important by the way we do have on the
board Queen A4 no no no no oh that's it
oh yeah you're right Queen
yes don't be jumping on me I'm just the
messenger don't get upset
[Laughter]
or he didn't play H5 he played Bishop G7
well that's surprising that's utterly
surprising I have to say queen to A4 H5
was a golden opportunity he played
Bishop G7 yeah but this Knight takes
porn in the air like well thank you I
mean I'm just I'm just anxious to grab
the pawn as well Knight takes uh D4 I'm
I'm confused and if you play I don't
know H5 I'm I'm ready to sync my uh
Knight
I have to say
so this is what I'm thinking
please he's looking at Knight takes D4
Bishop takes G2 yes yes Knight F5 no 95
I can take on F1 right yes that's
permitted I get two Bishops for no just
one yes you get two but I get the Knight
back right
yeah
and that's probably fine it's fine for
black because I have this D4 square
right you try to open up the position
with F4 at the end I have Queen D4
exchange the queens and enter the end
game I'm happy with that so the king
takes Queen takes D4 yeah yeah and now
you can just move the
Queen but you have some problems with E5
perhaps lone Castle now
okay and uh I've been anxious to put my
force of nature yes
oh this is looking super dangerous
dangerous yes but it's unclear whether
you get that much after the move Queen
to B6 right okay yeah well well this is
definitely a game that we want to keep a
an eye on let's just check in on the
game of Arenas right there uh when we
left it remember we looked at Knight
takes D4 my first
try failed miserably was Knight F5
Bishop takes F1
on the other hand check this out Knight
E6
forcing the cat yes forcing the capture
now you've lost a castling privilege
privileges after Bishop H5 check King
went to E7 Queen A3 check King to D7
King takes Bishop takes E5 wow Black's
King in the center and Levon says I
don't mind
is he right though I mean this sure
looks
I mean it looks really really dangerous
not that my king is that great of shakes
either
what's your impression at first at first
blush
I feel like black is
living on the edge the dangerous thing I
mean
okay Knight takes four okay so let's go
obviously to bring another piece in you
gotta defend it kind of right queen of
six can I
Upsy Daisy and over
that's one way also do you think
something else yeah I was also thinking
a move before but I mean probably you
can do it now D4 just between C3
Queen C3 oh that's a nasty that's a
that's a bad one yeah that's really bad
shame on me so I have to move back with
them yeah this is I tell you what I was
thinking please so instead of Rook A1 I
was thinking D4 let's go if you go yeah
backwards I go again you five come take
my pawn and then yeah yeah yeah you want
to get safety for your king I'm not
gonna go for that one guess who picked
up on the same thought processor you
just had uh Jovi uh our defense a
defending Champion Fabiano and yes also
like shaking his uh head
he doesn't like it well he knows he's
bastard well where else am I supposed to
move the night the Knight can't go to C4
this is this is the standard double
attack
um so I played Knight C6 and
I'm gonna have to say
like I will
give you the porn
not seizing anything look to D1 the only
thing you're seizing is five comes
immediately I'm seizing a handshake huh
yeah
Knight C6 D5 this looks devastating this
is actually just simply over
um like One Missed go back a few moves
what he missed was Knight to E6
this was the critical move okay the
critical Intermezzo not King takes G2
but Knight to E6 now you have to take on
E6 and I'm not going to take on G2 I'm
going to throw in a check first right
that's the problem by the way he took on
D5 we're going to see most likely Bishop
to G4 check keep the king in the center
to not allow it to go to B8 right and if
you manage to do that and you are
managing it to do that then the game is
pretty much over because all of my
pieces are and look at Levon how is that
King ever going to survive I think it's
not I don't think I've ever seen Lavon
have his King on these open highways
right out of the opening you just don't
see this in his games he because as
black he's super solid against one E4
and when he's playing D4 or against the
English he's usually playing E5 his King
never gets stuck so here what you've got
to go King E8 that's the only legal move
in the position Rook check doing fun
here yesterday exactly and well nothing
like a good King hunt uh early in the
morning to get the juice is Flowing
right by the way yes is linear just
simply a peace up now oh oh okay okay
we're gonna switch we think Lavon is
busted but also Samsung yes these these
two players uh were those two games I
want to say are in the
rapid
and we've got the two classical games uh
in the Champions bracket uh what's the
most uh I want to say clinical kill here
for Fabi Christian well Bishop G4 was
played yes King E8 on the board King E8
is on the board it does seem like Bishop
to H5 is
so we go back to D7 and now Queen to H3
instead of Bishop to G4 really this
seems to be the best way at least
objectively according to the engine King
D6 and rookie one and keep the bishopone
H5 so that you control Rook to E8
there's no more Challenge on the E file
and now it's very very difficult to hide
the key queen 2 F6 is going to be met by
Queen swings back to the other side of
the board take advantage of the dark
squares on the a3fa diagonal and now
that I have control of the e-file
there's no more King to E8 so after
Bishop to G4 King to d8 now I can just
simply go Rook to D1 set up my cannons
on the middle files and uh yeah this one
is just pretty much over you're playing
without the Rook on h8 The Rook on A8
the king is in the center with no Escape
path so this one is pretty much busted
if he finds Queen to H3 wow uh that's
remarkable because I was really eager to
play the move Bishop G4 and F4 frankly I
was thinking that I would you talk about
the Cannons and I I basically wanted to
open up the
e-file as well as the file with with
which is completely winning us also okay
Queen to F3 okay all right Queen F3 Let
me refresh my board that will that was
a surprise yes very good move as well a
very good move as well as well yeah well
he's just threatening Bishop H well he's
threatening I'm terribly uh crunchy
Levon needs to make a moves fast because
right now his only chance in the
position is put pressure on the clock
yeah if he manages to get Fabi down to
his last couple of minutes with a
complicated battle even if the engine is
saying that it's plus six plus seven but
with a very narrow path to get to the
king then he has a chance if he doesn't
uh take him down to his last couple of
minutes Fabi is going to have enough
time to find the PATH forward and uh
yeah that's going to spell Doom not that
I believe it at all but my first
hope would be you know like to play a
move like Rook H7 so I at least I can
protect myself I'll give you a check and
this is what I think he wants to do with
this move Queen to F3 he wants to give a
check on you want ah I check on the E1
yes yes I mean I can also go now that
you put the Rook on H7 I can in fact go
Bishop to H5 and then queen queen
hello
oh no oh no
oh boy uh Queen F3 looks pretty it's
good wow lots of lots of uh pass to
Victory let's jump to the elimination
bracket uh for another game that we
haven't seen uh begum versus atusha well
this uh terrible conditions it still is
the case but it's not the handshake that
you really really wait one second yes
there's no count pieces I know there's
an extra piece for white yeah but okay I
actually thought it was going to be mate
that's true
an extra piece should be enough I
understand but there's a big difference
between Checkmate and an extra piece
right I didn't even finally got your
king to safety after so many moves your
king goes to A7 you escape
congratulations
European style I know
look look look
give me some
the only good news is that your king is
not getting checkmated that's what
that's the only thing you're looking
forward to in life in this position
okay well I mean it's those small things
it's harsh but it's reality at this
point by the way the move Queen takes G5
strangely enough came with another
threat of actually taking another Bond
Rook takes D5 like for example A4 Rook
takes D5 Rook takes D5 Queen takes D5 uh
would actually just snare another pawn
and just say oops uh
no no don't do that yeah sir Rook takes
F7
at the end I have Queen G5 queen queen
G5
boys and girls is why you don't resign
that's right we're we're there's life
There's Hope right uh Rook takes F7 oh
oh oh oh oh you're probably still
winning I understand but it's again
that's not what you want the check made
and it's not the extra piece that he
currently enjoys what he does he did do
Lavon pardon me he did play Queen C2 by
the way that was a very crafty little
trick true he could have tried right hey
how about you take on D5 another Pawn
exactly
and in this case
I guess the problem is F2 or
why can't you try to take on but how do
you The Rook takes D5 so I take back you
take back with the queen only move
yeah and it looks absolutely
it it it's not yeah the the easiest yes
it's not great but it is something right
yeah it is a piece
yeah no here I'd probably just Retreat
the bishop and somehow I expect my
opponent to resign I don't know
uh okay well keep an eye on this linear
is also a man who's a piece ahead at
least when we left it uh just here is
when we left it and this one feels
on a different level yeah he's a piece
up but you know likes Pawns
what the kid pretend to be menacing okay
can somebody help me out here he played
Rook D2 followed by Rook D6
finger fail
like did he drop the Rook on D2 on its
way to D6 that's surprising uh okay
there are three connected pass bombs on
the king side
and the two Bishops are stunted yeah
Bishop takes and Bishop D4 on I mean
this should be winning for white but uh
it all depends on how dangerous is the F
Pawn Yeah
he wanted
Rick D2 threatening threatening Bishop
F2 and in case of Bishop takes F2 then
we'll fix G5 into meso check King G7 but
isn't the king better
than it is on GA it is my friend
so why would I put thinking on that's a
square like help me a king G7 Rook D6 uh
still winning uh I would say but okay uh
we'll keep an eye and Christian what do
you have Kicking and Screaming
definitely it's Sam Shanklin right now
it's not over yet right King pardon me
Roto F6 Rook F6
so how do you how do you do things right
now I would be just tempted to grab the
opponent A6 run with the a pawn
how about this idea why don't we go
Bishop to d8
Bishop to David a that's going to stop
well that that stops me from pushing me
together now E5
I'm trying to get the bishop to F6
so that your F Pawn is not supported
from behind but but is it so dangerous I
mean you can Park the bishop on okay I
understand
yeah no I know okay sir no he's going
first so E5
similar idea where I mean where are you
going to move the Rook is the problem
well if you go to F5 I go Bishop to D3
so it's gone G6 directly okay so he's
basically saying Bishop go ahead and
take my Rook which you say yes
because the bishop the bishop is got an
eye on it on F2 yes yes
well I'm expecting H5 G4 F3 go ahead
take the Rook make my day well oh pardon
me Rook D7 yeah no he's going for H5
on H6
uh-huh yeah no he he has to go for H5 he
does he does
I I suddenly realized that after for
example H5 Shaq King Rook it's a kind of
a zoo song you can't push the G Pawn
f-pawn is hanging you can't move the
Rook Rook G7 Rook here or Rook H7 made
so it's like
you're stuck you're just stuck and uh
well you can go Bishop G three he's done
H5 but Rook check and Rook F7 looks like
uh Bishop to G3 yeah Bishop G3 is
possible Bishop to G3 is possible yeah I
think that's my one move
it's actually really funny because I I
really did want to play Rook takes F4
and it was the only move to stop
your hand accidentally found the one way
to stop me from carrying out my thread
that's a very nice move Bishop G3 and
yeah well
again where there's life There's Hope
right
through
that H bar okay let's try to finish the
game somehow I know I mean yeah go ahead
all right let's go Bishop C5 right yeah
I'm going to try to take both of your
Rooks well this is actually a very nice
line too right yes precisely so who's
first wow it doesn't matter you're gonna
have to give up everything that's okay
I'll have to do it uh H3 keep going H3
keep going
somewhere I run away from you
yeah but then you go f
a b equals eight green look at this
nobody said it's going to be pretty
yeah one that's a lot of Pawns though
you know well
okay okay uh we'll keep an eye on this
one but let's go to the classical game
between uh Hikaru and Wesley because
that game is actually headed towards a
draw it looks like it's you know
accelerating as fast as possible which
is ironic because these two are the only
any ones and obviously in the open
section playing a classical game exactly
and they're the ones finishing first
right okay we did see this whole D4
business F6 we anticipated the F6 and
there was a massive uh uh trade trades
of and they just accelerated themselves
to this night upon an ending
and uh
yeah well I mean a draw really just
feels inevitable at this moment so not a
big not not a big attempt by uh Hikaru
today with the white pieces you know
what I reckon I think they're gonna
decide it all in in tie breaks well when
we saw that graphic of how they match up
in classical uh hikara said I don't like
my chances in the classical let's let's
take it to the rest of the blitz we've
seen them do this countless times you
know they prefer to and here's the
graphic that yeah you can see Christian
actually and in the classical matchups
you know when these two play you can see
that there's been one win for Hikaru but
four victories for Wesley so but in the
rapid matchups I mean so many so many
drawers but also a lot of points scored
I was about to say I mean you you have
these books you know the hundred best
games these two guys could write two
books based on Siobhan their all their
games and and I bet you they've been
really really good they're going to be
looking for a three-time repetition no
question about it let's jump back to the
game of Fabi and Lavon for just a moment
because our defending Champion
um was up a piece and let's see we left
it at Queen C2
we left it at Queen C2 King went back
Queen E5 Queen A4
wow I must say with this trade of queens
that kind of made things a little bit
easier I want to say for uh Fabi so A4
is that he's just trying to put the pawn
on
well on B5 like Rook day C4 what what do
you do author
I was about to say Rook takes E4
certainly has my attention what I mean
that was the first move that would come
to my attention as well but also
get distracted by forms can you not just
start lifting your age porn okay he
takes his Pawn these guys are greedy yes
yes they see upon the snatch it
absolutely I mean okay isn't it isn't it
time
it's probably time to go yeah H4 is well
maybe you could be like super careful
that's what I'm thinking
protect your little guys
Rook before that might be a little bit
over but I was thinking like I can turn
the uh uh to turn my attention ah B3
yeah protecting the little guys it seems
you are also very greedy
well she's been sitting uh beside me for
the last four or five days
suddenly you know
capture the pawn
I don't know but that actually you
appeal to my base Instinct Alpha yes sir
good no this is hopeless
basically I just wanted to make sure
[Laughter]
just just wanted to be he should return
the conversation yes exactly somehow
about B3 that's a great move
b2b3 uh protecting uh the little guys
this this looks like uh Bobby's cruising
he will win and let's see that game with
um Samson and look at this uh H5 check
Rook F7 Lanier just picked right up
okay and also Fabiana caruana
made a rather convincing game I have to
say against Levon aronian and to start
off his quest to stay alive in the
elimination bracket I think maybe not in
the rapid games
Jovi yeah come to my rescue please what
am I supposed to be doing ah e45 okay
clicked yes
then like I don't know how I always okay
so uh they're off again uh Lavon needs a
win as white he's uh uh
rule Royal Lopez Colin's favorite
perhaps he's taking some inspiration
from yesterday's match between Wesley
and Fabi because Wesley chose a similar
path to try to take the advantage out of
the opening against Fabi and he
succeeded in doing so yeah I mean is
this wise to repeat the same line
there's a roommate and lost yesterday
there is a wrinkle I believe Wesley went
Castle first instead of D3
so he went directly with castle and
after that defended that pawn on e4 in a
different manner
now we see this D3 move D5 Bishop to B3
Bishop to sorry yes you have the
position right now on the board I think
I need to figure out how to minimize my
uh screen here
no you're yeah you're all good this is
the position this is this is the
position the analysis board is not
perfectly and that was that was the
question I
you always have to ask is D5 playable in
those positions but uh
Bobby Bobby says no no no I'm going to
follow it up with this by the way this
was played yesterday because this is the
exact same position yes it was exactly
the same age six Bishop takes F6 this is
how uh Wesley not yet I think it was A4
Bishop B7 first yes and then Bishop G5
take on F6 and Bishop to D5 to set up
that and people stand corrected I think
you were right A4 Bishop B7 Bishop G5 is
how Wesley got here so we have a
different game right now because after
age six he decided a guest Bishop takes
F6 but with Bishop to H4 maintaining
that pin and big moment right now when
you play G5 yeah that's the top move and
according to my understanding of this
particular variation you you go for it
right it's that kind of combative
opening you know which shy away from
those big decisions go for it G5 but
this is isn't this also what uh
yeah and without hesitation Bishop G3 no
peace sacrifices for you uh
uh we we've all been on both sides of
those peace sacrifices but G5 Bishop G3
very very quickly Lavon I think is still
in his prep
and after
yeah that came just a second A4 came uh
no uh Bishop B6 A4 yeah and we're up to
date with the players now and uh still
we are in the Realms of theory and not
the most highly played Theory I have to
say but the most popular move according
to this database
B4 B4 Bishop G4 Rook B8 even Bishop D7
has has had a punter too Rook B8 was the
move chosen by Fabi followed by Knight
of dito immediately responded by Lavon
Knight aha that's that's a little bit
surprising because in conjunction with
the move A4 somehow I I had it in my
mind that he was going to go a b a b
Knight to A3 and maybe start to swing it
around to the night around towards the
F5 Square Knight D2 right away 9th wage
seven Fabiano is looking for something
the question is what is it King to G7
followed by F5 or is it H5 H5 is an
option as well
wow Knight to H7 okay we're the the
players are still in theory let's jump
to the game of Sam shankland and Lanier
as we know Sam is in a similar boat he
needs to win if he wants to stay in in
the tournament positions you do give uh
your opponent the the center a little
bit uh I while we keep the bird's eye
view there I was just seeing the game of
um Lavon and Fabi again boldly stating
the obvious Lavon needs to win and when
we left it it was just here and we had
seen the move Knight H7 and
um Christian was saying well is this a
Prelude to King G7 followed by F5 well
knows as man because yes it was F5 on
the board EF Bishop f593 this is truly a
Titanic theoretical battle between these
two players because and to my eyes Lavon
maybe has won the theoretical battle why
is that because he spent less time
it's very straightforward there's
nothing complex about this yesterday
wow okay I just spent less time he's
playing everything with confidence right
and he seems to know what he's doing
and what is Lavon doing by the way what
is his plan
Bishop G6 on the board on the board what
is he going to play for D4 is he
supposed to play for Knight D5 to try to
snack on that Bishop
um what is lavon's AIMS in the position
well it seems like Knight to D5
is appealing right let's go for the
bishop
that Bishop is always very annoying
whenever it's coupled with the action of
The Rook on f8 with an open F5 right
because F2 is quite tender right
um why not take it away from the board
Knight to D5 take it away take it away
now
A7 but it's loose well the one thing I
wouldn't want to do is I wouldn't want
to encourage white to play the move d4
which would open up the e-file uh I was
thinking that maybe I could turn the
Fate return the favor uh
um by pinning there was a bishop to G5
yeah follow pinning the Knight now it's
my turn to pin your night how about
Bishop H5 Bishop page five is nice as
well because it's annoying it's super
annoying because you know if you do
manage Bishop takes Knight which you
will then you've locked out the bishop
and then you go like okay let's play
Let's Play positionally please yeah I
mean I think it was the Kappa Blanco
Winter game where it was this bishop on
G3 which was hideous
it was like uh a piece down so maybe
Knight D5 needs to be prepped no 95 is a
great move and how do we answer Bishop
H5 then
you're going to lose the bishopon G3
this is what you need to understand
that's white uh you are going to take on
F3 H5 H4 now
what do I do to prepare for that I need
to open up the position your king is
pretty feeble on h8 okay
D4 let's go we open up the position you
don't take the bishop I'm not going to
take a bishop okay I'm going to keep the
Knight on D5 for the moment okay now I
agree with you that all I need is a draw
which is why I'm going to sacrifice
wait wait my piece
are you sure about that all right I'll
take your Facebook you give me the piece
I'll take it okay no
yeah all I need is a draw why did I
never play for a draw when I need a draw
because that's a way of losing the game
exactly and you kind of
your mindset it's a negative
predisposition you don't want to be
doing that exactly
so what if I defend with the move Rook
to each
do we have the Knight on D5 yes you have
to say something in the centers yeah
yeah okay well that's your extra piece
but boy it was I was hoping to
intimidating you know these coaches
they're not easily intimidated uh I
would be fretful let's put it that way
if I had the Y position how do how do
you feel sorry let me tell you I'm
inspired by my peace sacrifice yeah I'm
very inspired but I mean I'm a little
bit concerned that
can return the favor let me put the cap
on your your fun okay I'm not going to
go to E3 you're not no no take take
you're gonna sacrifice your queen no I'm
going to sacrifice my Rook Rook takes E4
yeah
I need to get to your king exactly wow I
I really need to get to your kingdom
that's my only goal in the position
yeah the queen takes D4 is is
frightening so I have to take this guy
yeah okay
yes yes and then I take this guy and
what if I continue taking and this is
the problem you you said my king was
feeble and it is
and boy did that ever turn out to be
prescient yes you're right you're right
well
you see my inner tactical Wizardry you
really did work you guys are probably
going to be surprised by this but it
seems like white is in fact objectively
winning right now after the move to D5
yeah wow the engine is giving white a
decisive Advantage wow no way and uh
just online to everyone this is exactly
what Lavon aronia needs you know he is
in a must-win situation exactly
so night so we were talking about the
theoretical battle and you had said you
know it was about the clock and so on
but it's it's shocking because what did
Bobby do in the previous 18 moves that
was wrong he chose the wrong plan of
opening up White's position and we were
discussing this and we were kind of uh
balancing between either F5 or H5 this
idea of Knight to H7 made a lot of sense
because you don't want to support the
pawn on G5 he chose the wrong one he
played the move F5 H5 was the right
solution well solution just the right
continuation right right approach F5 was
wrong no terrible after F5 in fact white
is just much much better with
specifically the moves uh that Levon
made I2 E3 follow it up with the natural
move Knight to D5 jump in the center set
up all your pieces on their ideal
squares and right now the pressure is on
Fabiano caruana okay and we'll switch
quickly to see the game of Sam Shanklin
again
um this uh this petroth boy I got to
tell you this and actually this bishop
on G3 is no longer
terrible in fact
that's a great Bishop that's a really
really powerful if I were white and I
could play F3 here and deny the E4
squared for the night I would think that
I'm winning yes winning yeah so in light
of that can you do something like for
instance
you better do something five yeah I was
about to say you better do something in
the immediacy because I can see the
Rooks are ready to pounce that's that's
okay
yes I've stated my intentions okay now
the queen
I really want to trade off some pieces
so I have to go
I understand
you want to trade Queens I want to trade
Queens but I can't do I say okay Queen
say it F6 uh
Queen F6 yeah but you just these three
easy block to Parry yes that is
absolutely true
yeah none of this will happen because
Fabiano is looking for an immediate
immediate counter shot and that is with
the move B4 which is what he played
after Queen D1 B4
but what about wow look to E6
doesn't that rookies
of that pawn oh my goodness rookie six
looks very compelling even though
take take
um
I think it must be a British thing
because I mean no it's American too we
say bomb takes bomb takes even though
we're we're supposed to be algebraically
trained these days but yeah it still is
still part of our what about Bishop F7
right now
thank you
Bishop F7 Rook tags Rook takes
sorry Bishop takes Bishop takes B3
apologies
okay which means the the highly
desirable Rook E6 let's go with your
move yeah sir I I think I really like
I'm starting to warm up to your idea of
Rook A7 Rook A7 or F3 okay K7 let's just
invade I mean let's be aggressive
aggression aggression I must win I must
win yeah
okay but you can just go ponte's Pawn
First
sorry
night now just brings forward oh wait do
you have a queen B8 wait wait do you
have queen bee I'm I'm
a queen B8 that's a double attack right
well that training is sure pain yeah
yeah you have some tricks and that's why
he played B4
because he's really really looking for
those conversations very instructive but
uh what is also very concerning on a
practical level I mean take a look at
love on a rhodian's clock 20 minutes
versus
Fabiano's under eight minutes that's not
good
let me fall back on the old you know
like I'm playing two Bishops I'm gonna
play the steinizzian uh way of
preventing the night from having a good
Outpost I'll play the move F2 F3 and
just give you the turn and say do your
worst how do you follow up your move
before
perhaps I will um take on C3 yes he
played Bishop C2 but yes you would take
on C3 in this case and and try to go for
Knight to try Knight H5 so now my my
Bishop can Lord over the position with
Bishop to C4 no it's really a very sad
position it is uh but having said all of
this bishop C2 uh Lavon had a very
simple idea he wants to put his Queen on
G6 that's right Bishop takes C2 Queen
takes C2 followed by Queen G6 would be a
dream for white so how do you stop me
from a cheating
that's what I wanted to ask Jovi
okay so you take I guess Don Queen takes
yes and now you remember the fundamental
principles of trade Queens trade queens
and you get fabby's following the rules
so when the queen does
on G6 you're ready to go Queen G7 let's
trade I like it okay but in that case D6
is going to be hanging
I'm gonna take
and put the question to you would you
like to take with the Rook
and allow Queen G6 so Queen G7 I got
Bishop takes D6 at the end or do you
want to play with a pawn which looks
pathetic
[Laughter]
it looks like a nasty and nasty choice
that Lavon can put to his opponent right
here with C3 takes B4
yes and I have to say if Fabiano loses
this one he will have to do something
different
in the next game whenever he's going to
have black because he's had problems in
this variation against West Wesley he's
having huge problems right now against
Levon he needs to do something different
whoops
not this one first of all just remember
that in the classical game we have a
drone yeah
everything they pay for tomorrow
and a very classical game tomorrow and
we decided and
and these two wow look at that wrap Wow
first of all 51
whoa 51 games of rapid play boy they
know each other very well and uh 17 wins
for Levon whereas fabi's had 11 wins
wow wow I mean yes uh shocking result
um the current position though Christian
if I can get you to jump in and uh tell
us what the engine thinks it really
looks like blacks and in trouble because
of his exposed King and lots of
weaknesses not a problem no no no it's
bad he's just he's completely lost it's
toast it's it's over yeah it's toast
okay pass Four Points by what four pawns
right now a pawn Advantage by the way C3
takes B4 Pawn takes and not Queen G6 but
just easy Central is a queen simple
chess go to D4
it's looking there as well ugly F3
Bishop F2 put the bishop on D4
the most beautiful queen I've seen
the tournament began yeah yeah that
Queen on D4 okay
supports the Invasion on the seventh
rank with Rook to A7 attacks the pawn on
B4 it does everything
well besides all that what have you done
for me lately yeah
I agree that that is a radiant radiant
Queen uh Sam Shanklin in a must-win
situation anything good happening for
him no that one is not even close linear
has neutralized his opening initiative
and right now he's
his import position and take this one
and take the uh for take the match home
for tatv uh again uh she lost the first
game with the black pieces she needs a
win uh against Naji at the two-time U.S
women's champion she just played the
move Queen F5 I kind of like that movie
so she's saying go ahead you want to
trade pieces but do it on my terms I get
to put my Bishop a little bit more
frightening
um yeah and I was hoping that I'd have a
a severely good follow-up and I I don't
know I'm not I'm not a big fan of of
sopping off pieces because you know
there is one thing I will say I always
love these Pond storms you know where
you get to go Rook to be Rook the D1 B5
it's not fun and games for black to be
facing defensively speaking yes I'm just
saying I mean it's not draw
no it's not draw but at the same time
you know you black does have a problem
with this Pawn storm but white has a big
weakness on D4 and that's something that
you know I if I were playing Black I
would yeah
immediately yeah so for example you
would go here absolutely more or less
required yeah and then I would start to
you know start expanding on on the king
side something like the F5 yeah yeah F5
and I'll expand yeah and then come on
push push it back what's that G5 G5
okay this is my language and there come
on F6
well I'm fighting on everything yeah
you're really and here by the way is the
Elimination Brackets as uh begum uh just
needs a draw to see her weight into the
next match and that one is definitely
going her way because let's check out
the position right now okay
gotten anywhere close to her opponent's
king and by the way we think he's on C3
we didn't get an H5 we didn't get in G5
we didn't even get an F4 G5 and we're
already seeing a black Pawn on C3 that's
not good no so and the race to the king
the first strike in and also you know if
you've seen B3 then A5 A4 is gonna
rattle down the board but it's uh Rook
E1 is an indication to me that White's
not a happy camper just the fact that we
can take and take on B2 means that
White's King is permanently damaged now
you probably don't even want to take on
people I know like that pawn the pawn is
such a wedge right so be sure maybe you
can take on E1 first and then go Bishop
36 you have so many options no this is
actually looking very very very good for
begum again now needs only it takes Pawn
takes Pawn
yeah not only that but I have a feeling
some Queen D5 to force you to go B3 and
then A5 A4
Mike Checkmate you if you don't pay
close attention to it so if I
for argument's sake yes she's traded
once so H5
right then you get in that way and then
Queen and then Queen
yes you can
my friends
open invitation agreed
yeah now this one is looking very very
good for vegan also on time four minutes
and 40 seconds for atusa 15 minutes for
Baguio right now and she only needs a
draw in this game nothing like having a
better position and draw odds at your
favorite you just feel really really
good uh once again let's jump to the
game between Levon and aronium because
we may be seeing another uh
uh playoff uh it should Lavon win then
they would play 10 minutes two games of
10 minutes plus five second increments
and if the match is still tied after
those two accelerated rapid games then
we go on to the blitz there will be two
games of three minutes plus two seconds
and finally I really am hoping foreign
faces I want to take chess back to the
streets right F2 F3 look at him go
because we mentioned that uh this I mean
queen on D4 is radiant yeah I mean
that's just such a gorgeous gorgeous
looking Queen but also with this move F2
F3 you know the bishop isn't going to be
too badly placed either on the Square D4
that would just be uh and recognizing
that The Rook was actually misplaced on
uh B6 Rook C6 but uh I see a slight
Shake of fabi's head there he's not
he's only got three and a half minutes
and it's going down Lavon has 16 minutes
so how do we do that until we go H4 or
yeah H4 makes a lot of sense Bishop F2
oh boy once you see that Rook you know
like tickling that pawn on G5 how do you
not play H4 but you can do it I think
about Leisure you can go H4 now I mean
because H4 allowed Rook to C5 and that's
why he played Bishop 12. H4 allowed with
the C5 yes challenge The Rook on the
fifth rank with Tempo makes sense okay
so that was why Bishop F2 a Prelude to
H4 yes
and Rook to E7
Jovi you have a golden rule when
attacking
don't trade changes no trades uh do we
like Rook A1 or do we like Rook D1 Rook
D1 Rook T1 uh you didn't get no he
didn't give us a chance to really get
into the uh Rook D1 looks good it looks
good you know tying this route to D6 but
also you know H4 is on top Bishop
actually I don't mind last sewing at
this Pawn either like Rook this Bond of
B4 is a real weakness and uh Rook B5
followed by Rook takes B4
got got my vote what about Rook F5
followed by Bishop to D4 got my vote
Queen E6 okay Fabby says enough of you
this nonsense I need counter play
Queenie Queen E6
not going down without a fight stop okay
Bishop to D4 right it it feels like I
have to get closer and closer to your
king it looks like a very good uh start
because you are
uh planning the desirable Rook F5 and
that would be
that would be huge and you survive if
you go Queen to E2
I doubt it right oh
just feels like this should not take on
D3 and then be working play Rook to E6
and
try to hang on for dear life
yeah it just feels like it shouldn't be
working but okay
um
it you know
no King F1 Queen C4 golden rule number
one
trade the queen right the queen
H4
exactly H4 I don't think you have time
for Queen E2 H takes G5
H4 and if you play G4 now
it's a a different uh kettle of fish
because the file can easily be opened
uh H4 looks like a very powerful move
on enjoying the moment
yes and what are the cost times the
clock times I'll just bring them up for
you so they are
Fabi has just under three minutes
whereas Levon aronian has just under 15
minutes so lots of time it's dark
difference in that
but still I mean he has to finish him
off exactly
who said that that is the most difficult
thing in chess is to win a win here
no I mean it's such a a famous quote I I
think it's you you got to go back back
back uh tarticover or something like
that you got to go way way way back
these guys are clever yeah I remember
the donor quote was like give me any
position to give me a worse position
give me a losing position give me and
I'll turn them around but give me
a winning position nah can't handle it
it's the winning positions that really
throw me off the losing positions I
understand and completely drawn
positions I get those nice
uh really one of the great uh quotable
and he did play H4 and by the way very
quickly G5 takes H4 I mean cover your
eyes but uh wow that is really
ugly and I think we're just about to see
most likely the end of that game of two
sellers who's begging all right right
now he's down to her last two minutes
but I think the writing is on the wall
on this one yeah we left it captured the
pawn on H4 and whoa whoa Bishops there's
2800s are difficult too
that's right and I'm looking at this
position I'm thinking well hang on a
second that's easy anymore not that easy
anymore right what what what what what
what what
that I I was about to say it was nice to
be able to lasso that beep on maybe it's
time just to play Rook B5
make sure that
yeah well Rook P5 looks like a very good
move
and it does seem like Shanklin and
linear are repeating which means that a
linear moves on wins the match and
eliminates Sam Shanklin from the
competition well Sam certainly came uh
very very well prepared his preparation
really remains world class but uh
well linear yeah Lanier you know he
remembered it's been a competition and
he played a great first game he didn't
really when he saw the opportunity to
strike he took it and well he will be
awaiting lenia Dominguez will be
awaiting the victor of this particular
match up Fabiana caruana against Levon
aronian and this one looked like it was
completely in levon's hands he was in
full control but now not so easy and
Fabby
is playing with just over one minute
and those developments that you were
talking about in The Elimination
Brackets here they are yes and we can
see the first person through to the next
stage is begin talking Genova and she
will be awaiting the victor of the match
between Nazi pakiza and tatev abrahamian
and we also have lenia Dominguez also
making it through to the next stage and
they will also be waiting for the next
person the next winner of Carolina and
aronian we love this bishop coming to
the D4 square and I think Lanier
Millennia Lavon has found the the
perfect setup he wants to play the move
Rook f8
tickling the night allowing therefore
when the night moves to play Rook to G4
and it's the black king that's going to
get netted in a checkmating attack so I
love this move Rook a rook A8
yes and go Knight H5 I know I'm probably
gonna check my age I I'm probably going
to get checked maybe but I need to do
something okay so check
I was about to say you desperate times
come call for desperate measures King G5
I would do G3 very quickly and that's
just something three there's a back rank
mate
so it's Bishop to E5 actually Rook to E6
is is that a move
absolutely continue tickling you like
that absolutely whoa whoa whoa it did
this is not that easy anymore wait a
minute it might have been a blunder just
whoa at first I said I saw it and I
thought oh Rook f8 what are you gonna do
well we saw what he could do king G5
might have let him Escape
wow Bishop he forgot about that move
King to G5 maybe rookie six oh I can
move my Rook he played rookie six I can
play Rook to B4 you can you can in order
to meet Rook takes with F4 check
and all the big question comes can I
play Rook takes
for Jack King G4
check King G3
with the I was just going to say there's
a rook check behind but there is a
rookie one right okay one is four uh
King F1 King F1 is also on the Move yeah
because I do have like you say I'm
waiting for a check from behind it does
seem like you're escaping with white and
that should give you the decisive
Advantage
but again Lavon has to win so he can't
make some decision like Bishop takes F
pardon me Rook takes F6 and how are we
doing on time Fabiano how many seconds
does he have left he has 20 seconds left
20 seconds against 10 minutes for Levon
Rook to D4 Rook to D4
not allowing The Exchange sacrifice
mentioned but now the
it is still white
it's true it it is a a dominant position
D4 is such a fantastic and also he's
gonna round up the B3 Pawn with Rick B
yeah but it's you know when he when
there were more pieces on the board I
think I think it was much more clear
is that winning a piece
you're absolutely right F4 check is
winning a piece because King G6 walks
into Rook A6 King F5 walks into the rook
f8 and after Rook to E6 I have G4
oh my word I I think that wins a piece
I mean I I I actually think you're just
winning the king and pawn end game too
yeah you know something as simple and as
a date as this and this and this
you just trade Rooks and then bring that
was my mile slip my bad I apologize and
then you bring your king
and that must be uh yes that seems so
I think that four just F and check
it could be a click that that might be a
clincher yes
I suspect that Fabi sees it and he's
trying to keep the poker face you know
he's trying not to alert his opponent oh
they both see yes yes Levon is just
calculating the exact line that you just
showed right now to make sure that he
can blast off a sequence of moves very
quickly in the mm-hmm
sorry and that's going to mean if Levon
takes this one home that we're going to
see another let's another another the
playoff will continue
um yeah excuse me okay 10 minutes plus
five seconds increment that's right our
apologies to Arena Crush Alice Lee fans
and he's missed it he missed he missed
Rook to F4 excuse me Rook to d8 is the
move that he chose which isn't terrible
I mean it freezes the night and oh with
one second on his side I think H5 we saw
this last year Jeffrey Zhang at one
second
and again F4 should be that winning
moment but he missed it the first time
he's probably going to play Rook to D6
yeah yes but
honestly that's such a good deal as well
there's no more
you don't even have Knight to H5 with
opponent H5 anymore six five five well
three
two so you have to do backwards
on H7 but now we take a pawn we check
our favorite living condition yeah
are there any tricks with the king
I suspect not because the problem is is
that this bishop is ready to
you know defend the dark squares if you
will and he did in fact after Rook takes
D5 he moved back with the King to G6 not
that uh this is any great shakes
uh what's better than being one Pawn up
two points out that's right and uh Rook
could B5 okay but I have an idea for
Fabi you know thinking
it's it's obviously a pipe dream for the
time being yes but if he can somehow get
H5 sorry H4 Knight comes to G5 and then
H3 you know just to disturb White's Pawn
structure a little bit and yeah
but a good one and I think Lavon said
you know what the one thing I want to
avoid is h4h3 and so he played five
and after Rook E7 I think it's inertia I
think that is at four wings right now
keeping uh Bobby playing F4 followed by
Bishop to F6
that finishes the game right
F4 King takes F4 Bishop F6 yeah
isn't there something no
you know I I'd probably at the board see
the move F4 and I couldn't bring myself
on the board you know I would probably
play King F2 and say you know like look
I'm just going to enjoy my I worked hard
for the two pawns but he did play F4 uh
well spotted Christian
yeah King takes F4 Bishop F6 and this
check is just it just goes to show how
powerful the bishop is in an end game
with an open Center and an open position
hang on a second hang on wait one second
wait one second there is isn't there
Rook E6
and you you're gonna meet Bishop takes
Knight with King age six now
you guys are Grandmaster hey hey you
know it was close
what he got his
oh
well he found a trick like you were you
you were trying as well but two pawns is
really sad it's too much yes okay
and I do have the table base in front of
me and it does say that it's winning
okay which doesn't come as much
well thank goodness for that right
King F2 Rook to D2
now every single king move wins
King E3 gift me the pawn but
unfortunately your king is a bit too far
away from the action very destructive I
I'm sorry I would the instructor for
Ukraine you gave up his extra Pawn well
look how he cut off the black king you
know he doesn't need to calculate any
more all he needs to do is just be for
King run
Teamwork Makes the Dream work that's all
you need to remember and then Teamwork
Makes the Dream Work you know you just
rush with the King
but I would have I would have nursed
those two extra pawns for quite the
while I must say uh tatev how is she
doing as this game is now technically
winning
um
whoa holy smokes one two three four five
six yeah
and Lavon has won
and in an hour's time uh they'll play a
very quick Rapid or will it be a blitz
10 minutes plus five seconds
then and then you know if the match is
still tied then we are going to see
three minutes plus two seconds Tata
fighting for her life can she do a
Christian
well I I don't know it says you know it
really depends on the black pieces I
mean how they handle that we saw
yesterday Fabiano crashed out to Wesley
so you know because he was very shaky
with the black side of an archangel what
is he gonna do now players already
Petrov I think Fabiano is going to go
down to his uh lost love the Petrov
right
and he had such great games in the
pattern of such great results back in
the days in the Battle of recently he's
more of a rui Lopez Italian or hangouts
and a lot of iterations of the Roy Lopez
but who knows he can still play the
petrol I can guarantee you that
the the players uh seem to be very
chatty with one another as they get
ready for this uh crucial elimination
playoff uh they're just like hey man
it's good to see you yeah you're looking
fine well it was interesting yesterday
uh we went to dinner with Bobby his
second uh beg him was also there my
student and
um we went somewhere close to levon's
place because he lives and he was
walking strolling around and he saw us
in the restaurant uh window he came
inside and he invited all of us to tea
and then Fabi said no I'm gonna play you
tomorrow I'm playing you tomorrow we
need to keep some distance right between
ourselves at least until this match is
over exactly and uh well Lavon has been
pretty stubborn with his 1 E4 in this
event he's uh tried his best we expect
E4 once again and will we see the Petra
yes no quick yes no oh
and look at this I mean I'm telling you
so most players believe in their
openings their stuff
C5 right
and do you just play bishopy no Jesus
said okay
maybe borrowing a page from Shaq
namidarov with his G7 G6 lines
yes yes why not and it works against the
white C4 as well as White's C3 it's an
interesting wrinkle
right
Well normally in the uh rui Lopez white
is not playing D3 D4 so oftentimes when
you're trying to play G6
fianchetto you you face a breakout in
the center with D4 which is a little
awkward in this particular case
you don't have such worries because the
Pawn's still on D3 Knight to D7
intimating that F7 F5 is on Black's
agenda right the same type of ideas
right that we've seen previously we've
seen uh those with the bishop on the
other side of the board in the previous
game and black Fabiano that is had huge
problems with his King's safety now with
the bispawn G7 the king feels much more
secure exactly and D3 D4
okay an invitation by the way that's
actually uh jumped out as a novelty
everybody up to this moment had played
the move Knight H2
which kind of everybody being only like
three players well there you go two all
three I should put it like that but D4
very logical looking move and well I
played Knight D7 for a reason let me
guess that it's F7 F5
um by the way the bishop is trapped
there is a threat of F5 F4 trapping this
bishop be careful on E3 yes exactly be
careful
it's true white does need to be careful
for the time being but Fabi really
playing very aggressively there
surprisingly so it feels like it's
playing right into levon's head
because E4 takes the F5 G takes I will
Rook takes F5 would just be a horrible
uh strategic approach and after Bishop
C2 you probably just much much worse he
takes F5 renews the threat F4 and sorry
Christian you were about to say that uh
something about this position is good
for white well I just don't like the
approach the overall very very
aggressive approach that Fabiano is
displaying in this match so far because
I feel Levon is really embracing those
type of positions he loves when the
center is open he loves when there is
creativity available in the position and
this is what we're seeing right now
okay but he's facing an awkward threat
he's F4 so this Knight on D2 has to move
maybe we have to start with Bishop take
C6 I mean how do we meet
the problem the problem Bishop takes
Knight seems to be to me it's quite
natural and then okay you need to make
room for the bishop so I would be
tempted to move the knight from D2 and
move it to usage okay Bishop takes C6 B
take C6 and I couldn't quite a few B3
okay so at least in this case we're
secure in case of f4 we don't
necessarily have to retreat we could uh
potentially Play Bishop C5 but it's two
Bishops uh aren't we happy is black that
we've earned the two Bishops it does
feel like black is nothing just fine
right now right is it time to just play
Queen to F6 you kind of cover the pawn
over here maybe on a good day the bishop
gets to go to H3 with the queen on G6
we've seen those uh things before and by
the way the players have followed this
line
we transposed to uh another players are
following us so they are like Fabby is
actually taking that same decision right
that you talked about you know developed
the queen is he going to push forward
with the pawns right continue with his
aggressive paths exactly quick question
for you F4 do you would you retweet to
d2c1 or would you go to the C5 Square
yeah I would be tempted to go there but
okay this does need calculation yeah and
I'll never Retreat
okay exactly and it just feels like
white spaces are kind of loose and
hanging a little bit right I mean
because E4 and the bishop on C5
well sorry what's the bishop doing on C5
what's the Knight doing on B3 yes yes
yes yes and give it a time give it time
now now you're gonna do this I'm gonna
go Bishop to D4 and say let's trade
let's look at your king I like it 95
let's go or Knight F6 now if you go 95
I'm taking that pawn so you have to go
hmm
yes you are yes you are but okay let's
keep going 95 so I'm kind of curious F3
let's go
uh you want to start with F3 yes I I
want to test the waters
uh
G3 yes they wanted to test
you're really going for it one second it
doesn't work because I can Retreat the
bishop
okay Knight takes F3 yes that's my idea
Knight takes F3
rats but you're close I mean and you
don't have to go Queen H5 I know but I
was uh you could go King G7 and that did
look terrifying okay in F6 so Queen F6
is a preparation a preparatory move for
uh
F4 E4 it's all good knight B3
Queen F6 correct I like
it so quickly rookie one
rookie eight
okay so this kind of sidesteps the tempo
of Bishop C5 so it doesn't mean that F4
and E4 are coming quickly and now I
understand why previous games have gone
Knight H2 just kind of getting out of
the way of that uh what what if I
actually go Queen to D2 the very natural
Queen
but you were inviting yes you were the
poems to yeah
we sure did I mean Head Over Heels or
heels overhead something like that Queen
C2
okay now you can go F4
okay but at least I guess in this case
I've taken over the E4 Square so it
means that if I do have to move my
Bishop at least not uh facing
um but this feels very shaky because you
know you can see trades happening the
bishop on C8 will come to life
okay I'm thinking it's time to just
reroute this guy go play Knight f8
Knight G6 leave your pawns on these
beautiful squares E5 and F5 control as
much as the center as possible just get
your knight to a
good aggressive post on G6 I think
that's that that's the right plan I mean
I I agree I I gave up control over the
C5 Square I just say go ahead and use it
then he should do that after Knight f8
you should come forward because you've
got to be ready with some control over
E4 right so 1965. that's the consequence
of your last movement yes but nothing I
can do about that one no the night's
over there but I can you do have a loose
piece on E8 so can I pile on the
pressure
that's something crazy like Bishop to D4
yes well right now I've got that guy
defended once I've got E5 defended once
twice Thrice
but now I can go Queen F7 which is going
to actually uh
right okay that was not the intention
no it wasn't but I like the aggression
you know the aggressive intent yeah okay
but uh outside of knight f8 uh well he's
he's thinking about his uh he's thinking
for a very long time right now last five
minutes and 30 seconds just having to
refresh my board
he's down to what I'm sorry five minutes
and 30 seconds against eight minutes and
15 or 13 seconds by the way that was
really so overwhelmingly true in the
rapid game it was like 18 minutes for
for Lavon three minutes
I mean he was really burning clock uh
greatly I want to say and it finished
with 10 minutes sort of live on in one
second or for Fabiano he played one move
with one second yes and at one moment he
was down to the scene also his last five
minutes this is not an encouraging sign
for Fabiano right now no
nope and he has to bear in mind that
he's getting less increment per move as
well because it's only five seconds
exactly well again outside of Knight f8
okay I was about to say
besides Knight f8 what could he play and
he found it Queen F7 was his alternative
well I must say not that inspired by
Queen of seven the problem with this
type of long things yes is that not only
that you burn your clock but your
confidence level kind of decreases as
well yeah I agree with that yeah because
you're like I'm not finding moves I I I
cannot make my decisions in time and
this guy is just blitzing his moves he's
making decisions so confidently what am
I doing wrong you start doubting
yourself you start asking these type of
questions agreed uh why this move uh
Jovi uh is what is it about Queen F7
that's attractive well I I liked it you
did I did like it for the primary reason
that I it's not very easy for white to
come up with a plan let's be honest
about that and the Korean F7 does
protect the king very good news when
your king is exposed but also it can
transfer itself to age five which is
what I I have the Golden Rule yes and
the golden rule is you want to try you
you want to attack my my king so there
was this move Knight A5 with the idea
Queen B3 to trade queens and to tickled
the pawn on C6 Lavon played Rook D1 E4
Knight D4 right away now you're about to
explain to me that the queen can go to
H5 in certain moments yes absolutely I
mean
1995. I'm I'm assuming or either that or
F4 well F4 does have a drawback right
yes
okay the pawn on C6 is hanging upon on
e4 is hanging but anything outside of f4
also well 95 no no now we understand
that the queen on F7 also has purpose it
did does defend the Rook I don't think I
want to do that though what do you want
I think I want to do Knight E2
Knight E2 and go to F4 he is me Knight
E2 beautiful
[Music]
now you're gonna sacrifice in exchange
probably have to because you don't want
to allow F4 I'm sure about that F4 F3
and Bishop takes H3 uh I mean I
understand if you get a knight to F4
you're happy but uh okay let's try to be
a bit more clinical right now what if I
go
Knight to C5 I don't want to allow you
to go too deep I like Knight to C5 it
covers D3 brings your knight which isn't
doing that much I must say
he's going for it it sure is
F4 okay Bishop to C1 we can anticipate
this one
quickly quickly and uh okay so the big
thing is obviously you've got to start
kicking with the white Knights what
about C5
indeed C5 everything with Tempo yep I
like it
C5 let me just pause here for a moment
because
um
okay uh 92. keep going yep F3 F3 now the
question is
am I
am I exposing my king or am I
uh
am I in trouble C5 is on the board it's
the most challenging reaction probably
down to his last two minutes and 49
seconds against six minutes and 50
seconds but don't you guys feel like
fabby's going all in on these last few
moves yeah like I mean there's no he's
Bridge burning there's no
recovering from this and he we do have
Knight E2 I think F3 is it's forced it's
forced at this point yeah yeah F3 is
forced and then you just went all in
if it works it's great genius yes
exactly but if it doesn't you're going
to lose it miserable strategical way I
mean that's just the way it is to quote
Luber mayor leboyovich if it doesn't
work you're gonna lose miserably
miserably okay E3 not F3 not even F3 E3
whoa ah this this move has a lot of
point to it as well because you know
when I was listening yeah F3 and also
you extend the line for the light Square
Bishop you can park itself on B7 is that
true just a second I take F3 Rook F1
Knight F4 I think and it kind of not
Rook F1
I'm a bit concerned about actually
taking on E2 and taking on D1 and taking
on F7 I've got Queen F3 check B5 or
queen ft three he played tape and he has
played F3 as expect again all in
all in uh these last four or five moves
by Fabi he's gone talked up at night
no funny business with Rook F1 that felt
like the right move to me as well and
what about Bishop Beast
Bishop B7 I mean after all if you're
going to if you're going to put a Pawn
on F3 and you're going to take you might
as well put your Bishop on B7 as well
the desirable Knight Knight Queen B3 how
do we feel about the exchange sacrifice
oh then you're gonna try it off Queens
Golden Rule I I've learned from the best
[Laughter]
guy ladies commentator visually it
doesn't feel like Fabiano has enough
attackers
to complete successfully this attack
well nobody is over on the king side
where the party's over right yeah
nobody's over there I mean yeah I get
the idea that you're attacking but your
knight your Rook on A8 your Bishop on C8
they're not you have to sacrifice
another Pawn with Knight D5 no Bishop to
B7 he's done and we we were looking at
Knight A5 I must fight I must say I'm
attracted to not move in order to trade
Queens there's a big opportunity right
now which takes D7 yes
let's calculate 67 Queen takes D7 no it
takes Pawn Knight takes C5
Queen has to go to I guess C6 but then
you have a check C6 is probably no I
have to go to B5 B5 yes to stop yes
but this is
attractive because I'm looking at Queen
G6 possibilities this looks
like I guarantee you Levon is looking at
this as well
but you know hang on a second if you
calm down and you're like okay I gotta
restore connection between the queen and
the black king you can just make moves
like for instance Queen B6 but that's
three Pawns
for the exchange right now I've got two
if you just allow me as you were about
to say if you just allow me to take a
third Pawn I got a feeling I'm liking
white okay so there is this moment on
the other hand can I play Queen G6
I mean that is still a night hanging on
D7 right
I mean
and I wouldn't mind terribly trading
Queens
uh does look like opportunity here for
Lavon uh that's right that's why he's
thinking that's why he stops he's
thinking he feels the critical moment is
coming he's feels like he's Reaching
Forward G6
once every broadcast here it comes you
ready well these guys are good
they are so good
Queen G6
Jovi's golden rules when when you feel
your opponents attacking your king trade
Queens
and I must say that the more you look at
it it's not bad Pawn on C5 that's a very
uh tender Target
Queen takes G6 Knight takes G6 Knight to
F4 back Rook to d8 and the simple Knight
F4 back do we take on G2 or do we uh
yeah you have to extend that Bishop
diagonal right
you have to take on G2 you just don't
want to see this Pawn even
going to E4 uh and somehow losing a
Tempo is why you don't you don't want to
see E4 on the board and uh talking about
the clock times yes Bobby is 47 47
seconds and it's ticking down and
remember he only gets a five second
increment per move so basically right
now
they're playing a Blitz game yes in
which Levon has almost five minutes four
minutes 30 seconds again
wow that's not even on my radar I like
that movement and I was wondering E4 is
just resigns E4 resigns no E4 resigns
because you can't take with the Rook
why can't I take with the bishop then I
take on F3 and I take the rook and I
take the Knight but I go by five
okay just a second E4 Bishop takes E4
Pawn takes F3 Bishop F5 so I'm a pawn up
and
no no way of pinning and winning
you do have a knight takes C5 though
Knight takes no not not right now but in
the instead of Mercury
uh
okay Bishop is on A8 so just a second if
you go Bishop back
I could also play Knight to D oof I
don't know this looks really attractive
to me I would play E4 by the way after
E4 can I take on G2 first like uh-huh E4
Pawn takes G2 I know your tactics
already yesterday you tell me how
winning you are and no this is so good
sign I mean come on okay Knight to D5
Knight to D5 so let's see E4 after HD2
put it on the board oh sorry E4 F takes
G2 Knight to D5
and um finally Knight to E5 why not
Knight to E5 why not
and I have to take the I have to pause
I don't want to see Knight F3 check and
now can I go C4 followed by
93 if you allow me yeah but you're not
going to allow me this is uh well uh it
it's not as clean as I thought I must
say let's put it that way I was hoping
for something a lot simpler uh
okay if I don't play
well one thing is for sure this moment
this bishop to A8 definitely forced a
pause from the one because now he's down
to his last two minutes he had four
minutes so he spent four minutes and 30
seconds now he's down to enormous amount
of time on this moment
so he obviously feels it's crucial
and it probably
is he's probably right but I mean I
think I would have played E4 uh several
minutes ago uh just because I I really
wanted to close that diagonal and to put
a knight on D5 maybe he's looking at the
immediate Knight defense I was gonna say
because you know if you provoke F6 well
yep
Oh you mean provoke C6 yeah sorry yeah
yeah that Bishop on a will hate you for
the rest of the game so that's not a
good movie
he took and immediately Knight E5 this
was in my book almost an illegal move
yeah you don't want it you don't want to
allow the Knight with it well you got to
go King F2 you have to yeah so you kind
of bit the night well yeah then the
Knight captures this is not what you
wanted with white
surely not
I mean because now the Knight has a
beautiful Square C4 C5 C4 okay well
Knight takes C4 well I mean Knight to C4
Knight is
I'll get there Knight to C5
and he goes for it
E6 is looking tender
still you have your your E4 ideas on tap
oh absolutely I'm Dreaming to close that
bishop and maybe on a good day even use
the G file that would be uh 20 seconds
F6 reminding white you got a king too he
takes and like I'm on e4
came to eat too wait wait wait a minute
he need to he's very fast and he's
showing that Knight H4 96 wait a minute
how do you defend no sorry Knight h496
and the porn F6 is hanging the
other night
26. oh yes oh yes wait how how do you
defend now ten well there's a rook D1 is
Rook takes F3 of Five Seconds to find
out
D6 okay because there's a rook D1 if we
take twice Rook will come to D1 and it
will ensnare the bishop but then I go
92.
then that wins Rook takes F3 is a winner
and he's done it had did Fabi just like
uh black out on 92. I think it did oh he
just shook his head I must say signaling
the fact that he missed this yeah okay
but is this such a disaster I was
thinking
and he gives a check no but King G2 now
okay and then rookie won
and then when you play King F2 Bishop H4
check
oh maybe he lucked out
because this is so this is a draw then
the king not quite so fast so what if I
so I go King G2 rookie one Knight E4
inviting you to take my knight King G4
rookie one perhaps not only four right
uh sorry he went King G4 immediately
apologies maybe now is the time to
provoke that King to take a step forward
with H5 sorry what about this I go King
F3 back now I go King G2 yes then I go
King F2 I
force your Bishop to go to H4 and then I
go King F3 back okay and then when you
give me the check on F1 I go King G4 and
I attack the bishop which is exactly
what he's done nice catch there uh
Christian because then the bishop will
be hanging oh after Rook F1 he found it
this is over yeah two pieces will
overpower The Rook two pieces and a pawn
a very important part that e-pawn
exactly exactly by the way seven five
seconds Bobby and Paul King F7
this was not a move he wanted to make no
it's just it gives gives white the
opportunity he needs to maybe play a
move like night to E4 and bring the
Knight to G3 like a very sensible move
Knight to E4 Knight to G3 just to
reinforce but yeah by the way E4 yes
liberate that Bishop
who indeed and Rook checking of boy did
Lavon jump at that opportunity to play
King
and Knight takes A6 why not give me that
pawn
Rook E1
and he's gonna do the same thing it's
like some sort of a triangulation
process it's almost a study it's
incredible and you cannot do anything
about it King to F to Bishop to H4 check
King to F3
so crafty what a concept that's art
right there exactly it truly is
and now we've got Bishop takes H6
potential you can take that you can take
on C7 again well I'm just saying the
bishop on C1 has been such a
horrifyingly uh passive piece now you
you took away a crucial
uh counter play Pawn upon that might
have been for counter Play Bishop back
to F4 and now you're now you're home and
dry now it's very easy
yeah yeah this one is uh is looking like
it might be close to over yeah because
we've got to pass a pawn two in the
position which makes it so much easier
I'm still stunned by this King G2 King
F2 King F3 it's nice with only a few
seconds on it exactly King F3 yep
by the way Knight E3 is ready to pick up
some more pawns over there and uh the
white king stepping forward each time
that King comes to G4 there's a bishop
nicely waiting for the king to arrive in
the tempo Bishop E3 E3 again very nice
eyeballing this Pawn all the squares
stopping Rook F2 you're right about that
yeah but also just let me take a look at
how protected his pieces are beautiful
if you can step back with a king not
again he can move the knights
no but each time he wins a crucial Tempo
and picks up a pawn he can just move the
knights the bishop is protected but
that's not it's not only that
it also frustrates Fabiano oh without
question this is so frustrating right
now oh without question that is so true
you just feel like
you know you're on the wrong side of a
study
that's how it feels
now the bishop goes to D4 once again
finds this perfect square King goes to
F5 King in the middle King F5 is a
King F5 E5 Knight to F4 E6
wow well I I I will borrow what you said
this was Art very very very artistically
played and uh Lavon will be very pleased
with this game because that whole King
G4 we saw once twice I mean this is like
really good great stuff because it feels
so good about himself right now right
and once again that's dangerous if you
are facing him in a must-win situation
as far as right right but then again
Fabi had his chances yesterday with the
white pieces against Wesley he surely
will try to find something in this match
as well and I was talking about it at
the beginning of this playoff he needs
to do something differently with the
white pieces also because
in their initial encounter Fabi did play
this move C for the floor McKenna's but
he didn't get much out of the opening it
was in fact Levon who had the advantage
Fabi will have to go back and understand
why he needs to do differently I'm very
very eager to see what he's going to
come up with for those and again and
this playoff of Lavon takes an early
lead against our defending champion and
probably will have to win to extend the
match for those of us joining us late uh
first of all shame on you but what
really really caught our eye Christian
was this beautiful concept right here
and it happened not only once but
several times King F3 Rook F1 check and
it's like this awkward thing your your
piece is you know like the night on E2
the bishop on it you see one or stuck
the King has to defend so then you go
okay but I have Bishop H4 check and then
the point is is that after Rook F1
uh you you get to pick up this Tempo
against the bishop with King G4 and it
was a theme that recurred uh several
times in this game here we go and here
we see it again Levon just being mean to
be honest it was unnecessary I thought
it was great there we saw it again
and
one more time you know that was like
it's not a three three move repetition
you know I picked up a few pawns yeah
nice nice nice we just tip our hat so uh
and it was the only way out in fact I
was looking at uh at the end of the
engine right now is the only way to not
have to uh accept the repetition right
with Rook F1 rookie one Rook F1 rookie
one exactly it's King to F2 yeah the
bishop to H4 and then go King to F3 to
attack the beautiful beautiful this is
Art yeah the one linear Dominguez it
certainly it is how in his room uh
watching this uh match because the the
winner will play against him tomorrow
tomorrow exactly in a rapid match and of
course it was a wild game you saw just
now and both players now need to reset
because there is a second game on the
horizon and this time Fabiano will have
the white pieces and when will that game
begin uh
no
probably just a couple minutes away uh
sorry uh Christian you were saying that
Fabi needs to do something more with the
white pieces he's not getting uh the the
good stuff yes and perhaps I should show
it uh let's see if I can find that game
this was the crucial game today he
started off with the move C4 Knight F6
this Knight C3 floor mikenus with E6 D5
against E4 and we got to this position
Bishop to F5 by the way I was explaining
it's the most precise move in the
position D4 take take take the three
Bishop D5
but the problem is after Knight to C6
Bishop to F4 H6 Bishop to G3 G5
Queen to A4 was the bad perhaps this is
it we found the answer as well Bishop to
G3 was the good move instead of the move
Queen to A4 19. maybe this is what he's
going to try to come up with Knight to
D2 and try to open up the position with
the move F4 transfer this Knight
potentially on the other side of the
board but also open up the discussion of
maybe trading off this force of nature
on D5 the bishop 25 with the move Bishop
to F3 this might be what Fabiano is
going to be coming back with let's see
okay actually I do think that never mind
none of that we have we have E4 no C4
and we're gonna say Levon try to
batten down the hatches and play
something solid
it's looking for
the game but I can't find it ah
we had the wrong the Berlin
Berlin with Knight to D2 Bishop 36
Castle Bishop 26 back a very solid
approach by Levon we expect this he only
needs a draw to finish the match remain
in the competition
and kick the defending Champion out of
the competition right now a golden
opportunity for the honor Romeo
what is that Knight doing on B3 I must
ask it's uh allowing the bishop to get
out that's about it not much else
see Queen D7 inviting Bishop F6
Fabi wanted no part of that and he
played Bishop H4
mm-hmm
Bishop to H4
I assume it's Bishop G3 Bishop G3 and
then try to play for C3 D4 is that is
that the plan well to take the pawn on
E5
and I'm presuming that the Knight is
gonna go to C4 and sit on E3 yeah I
don't like the queen on D7 but I do like
the queen on A4 funnily enough what do
you think about that you go Queen A4 you
kind of stop C3 you kind of stuff they
play B3 right yeah okay three and A4 and
put the Knight on C C4 and start looking
at the E5 Pawn okay Queen A4 B3 Queen B4
I'm just lurking
on an odyssey exactly exactly it was a
closed position I mean in the close in
these type of closed positions you can
get away with medievas like this exactly
do you have that in a queen Sally yeah
Queen sortie well the sortie yes but
Sally yeah I've had it Queen Sally but
it's okay
I'm slipping here a knight G5 Knight H5
Knight G5
okay he obviously he wants to play for
night F4
mm-hmm
but Knight F4 was that
allow me to go a G3
G3 Knight to H3
well no wait a minute I mean G3 Knight
to G6
oh yes what have you done that's not a
nice way of treating a bishop I agree
yeah isn't um
fabiana's plan to trade off the night
yes bishop and then then swap off his
Knight for the light Square bishop and
say I've got a good night against Bad
Bishop that's exactly the uh
the point he's trying to make now he
takes E6 I'm assuming Queen takes E6 and
then you say Swap this one off too and
then play Knight versus Bishop
nope he's played Knight takes E6 he said
maybe you did have the intention of
taking my knight on F1 Knight to C4 F6
the bishop on D6 is well and truly a bad
piece but they do say bad Bishops make
excellent Defenders and those uh are
good pawns that he is defending uh for
the moment this bishop on H4 which is
your good Bishop is exactly a great
diagonals like uh
how are we going to get eventually we're
going to have to play a break right
whether it be C3 or C3 D4 or F4 you've
got to get in a break and it very much
depends on where the Blackman's Castle
is excuse me that was just well yeah I
agree with it you Christian but I mean
the problem is that if you go F3 I mean
the position is so closed that you can
even go G5 okay yeah that's probably the
F3
A5 by the way takes away another
potential break a3c3 B4 you're not going
to be doing that
so it's attempting to just lock the
position down that's exactly oh okay
he's going H5
same idea what did he do after H5 and
now A4 A5 A5 A4 A5 A4 and H5 H5
whoa is that saying that okay I believe
racking is not going to Castle yeah
it's completely closed but I must say
it's not every day that you see A5
attacking on the queen side followed by
H5 it I mean you're trying to take over
the entire board you know A5 H5
84. well he is trying to take away and
guess what he's he's trying to shut down
F4 and for the moment he's saying I
don't believe C3 and D4 will bring you
Advantage so I'm not going to allow you
F4
that's okay
H3 H3
okay so I mean if I'm
if I'm intuiting uh Lavon I'm thinking
he's going to play G5
G5 does give
R square great you have one good piece
well done me that's it right you you put
your knight on F5 and you know then you
can start working your way up with C3
you still have the break D4 again
I would say that I have more than one
good piece
I'll go C3 after that
by the way
Colin who visited Us in the studio from
the Make A Wish Foundation kid he just
struggling with cancer he said I want to
go to St Louis I want to visit the St
Louis chess club and I want to meet
these guys
and he said very clearly that Hikaru is
somebody loves watching on the Stream
and he's wearing that beautiful American
Cup jacket yeah and then we do have oh
sorry we do have G5
kindly played some
get him oh that was very nice and you've
made a big promise yes sir to get his
letterman jackets science and look at
Chris bird how attentive he is
that's that's a true Arbiter right there
he's actually a chess lover
he's like he's got he's got a front row
seat he wants to enjoy it there was a
funny comment on Twitter of a picture of
Chris bird watching over one of the
playoff matches yes and the comment was
saying Chris bird more like Chris
vulture Chris Walter
yeah
yeah they're very attentive okay well we
have a development because LeBron has
castled Queen side which does mean that
Fabiano's job is now a lot easier he has
to open a line over there as yes as
indicator
I think this is a good news Aviano yeah
but good luck with that well first of
all D3 is hanging so it's going to take
preparation to play C3 and look at how
many times B4 has been defended so he's
basically said uh you know you've got
one good uh piece the Knight on F5 your
Rook on A1 it's not great on F1 I I I
don't I don't disagree with you the only
thing is that the reason why I'm saying
is good news for Fabi is because the
plan the long-term plan has now become
clear he can just like improve his
pieces I mean he's simply going to move
his Queen now he has to actually drop
back to E3
I I know but you know he eventually the
plan is going to be clear this neither
five seems to have been a misstep though
yeah yeah was it mistimed I think so
because Knight D4 just forces the trade
and what do you trade on D4 with is the
question well if you take with the
bishop so yeah
Bishop takes C5 tags and the bishop will
go to C5 it might be strapped yeah
there's no way to get uh any play in the
position so he's gonna have to retrieve
93. even if it Retreats themselves he's
done it it's also possible for Lavon to
start thinking about breaking through or
playing solidly okay so he also Retreats
whoa now I would not have played that I
would have played King B7 and just said
deal with the Knight on D4 I would want
to provoke the move for C3 King H2 King
B7 King B7
situation both sides are very evenly
much
around the seven and a half and seven
minute Mark yeah
darkness in Norwegian does it yeah okay
wow
and uh well with your I said six months
of winter
Mark's a favorite time of the year I'm
sure
Knight to C4 uh Christian I gotta tell
you this is a dream position for Lavon
all he needs is a draw to to knock Fabi
out of the tournament and it's blocked
as block can be yeah yeah it's great
yeah and I don't see the the plan is it
B3 Queen B2 followed by C3 and B4 if you
manage to get all of those moves sure
yes but whenever you go B3 queen beat y
just Retreat my knight to C6 and you
cannot play the move C3 because the pawn
on D3 is hanging so I just don't see the
active plan at the same time
take it down to the last minute right
make some waiting moves rookie one row
to D1 Shuffle the pieces pretend like
you're doing something like threatening
the flex exactly and then in the last
minute just throw the patties
it is what it is you might lose that's
fine you make a draw you're out of the
tournament no matter what right
yes I mean we saw Ray Robson beat Sam
Shanklin by making these lots of waiting
moves very very patient but he had the
the pawn in the pocket and uh Sam had to
you know navigate through all kinds of
ghosts in this particular case the
position is so blocked
you're gonna have to keep an eye on the
uh 50 move rule funnily enough finally
enough in the middle of the game you
know in the middle of the game it is I
mean because
I mean the 50 move rule is that if the
player doesn't make a poor move or a
capture for 50 moves then that they can
claim a draw at some point he has to go
B3 right yes B3 defend upon on A4 and
get ready to play the move C3 I'm a
little bit surprised by the move King B7
I myself would have probably played Rook
to A8 to absolutely absolutely
discourage C3 and B4 because then The
Rook on a queen on C6 would be attacking
the a pawn but
possibly a king walk to the king side is
the king side safer than the queen side
King D7 King E8
so the way I see it you have to put the
Rook from D1 on the C file
okay and then put the Rook from A1 on
the B file okay and then go B3 and C3
and B4
okay give up the pawn on D3 and I think
in anticipation of exactly what you're
saying Christian uh Lavon is going to
say whenever you play C3 you're going to
make the pawn on D3 a Target I'll have
to give you that pawn I I will have to
say what part my hearings you're going
to give me what
yeah how do I sign up well eventually
that I mean Kristen is Right eventually
that's what's going to have to happen
you have to if you want you need to roll
the dice because objectively this
position is draw exactly
that's the problem
that's the problem and I was saying that
he needs to take Levon down to his last
minute the problem is LeBron has six of
them is he's slower than levonne right
now
this Rook 2 d8 I don't like this
doubling up let's
let's hit first
[Music]
okay Queen to C2 defending upon on D3
now maybe B3 is going to come next B3
has to come next
but that's such a slow uh you have to
defend the night on
C C4 really protects everything over
protect everything are you considering
F5 I am I'm ashamed of myself but yes
you you you caught me you caught me
thinking about it don't break the
harmony yes I know I mean I shouldn't
all he needs is a draw and he's through
and I'm playing F5 trying to attack uh
fabi's King side he did play Rook d8
Rook D2 so
uh piling on the pressure but easily
thwarted with the move Rook D1 now
I'm not very pleased with the black king
on C8 there is a possibility of Queen B3
and Knight takes B6 check so
um he did play King B8 by the way which
makes sense
not only that but with a king on C8
after you open up the C file D4 exchange
on D4 and the C file opens up I have
ideas of Knight takes B6 right
fair so King on B8 seems to have found
the perfect place for black
but okay five minutes and 10 seconds
against 5 minutes and 57 seconds time to
shuffle with the bishop I think put it
back to G1
as wide as what you know just
okay
I think he heard you and he shuffled
back with his Bishop Bishop f8 Queen the
B3 there's some tactics
you know Queen B5
I think say five yeah oh Knight takes A5
yeah very good
big trick on the board Lavon of course
will has to be aware definitely I've
noticed that yeah maybe it's time just
to defend the queen
uh Rook to E8 perhaps
make sense Queens can we go D4 now I I
after Route 38 maybe you can step back
D4 how many
I'm uh failing to calculate how many
attackers you have versus how many
Defenders I have
uh keep going yes yes yes so I think I
think it's okay but at the end of the
day
my Bishop isn't so bad you know that
right yes but I have coming to D5
finally at least I got something right
right well you got an imbalance I'm not
sure it's that favorable but you can
break out with F5 Queen he played Queen
to E8 not Rook to E8 sorry sorry Queen
to B3 Queen to E8 yeah and so Knight
takes
right
Knight takes B6 takes now the queen will
defend C6
and the attack is completely refuted No
sacrifice there
do you invade with a queen queen B5
where am I going after King B7
probably nowhere I mean we it's sort of
like we're we we have the standoff yeah
I mean you you've achieved basically
maximum you can draw I'm a big fan of
dropping the bishop back to G1 okay just
to kind of be around the king and have
everything overprotected and also clear
the E3 is on the trick guys
now I go
D4
David four yes
wow
Queen E6 he actually played
um so the trick was there was something
hanging on E8 there's Knight takes A5
whenever you take with a knight on D4
working on B7 well I would be taking
pieces right yes you would be taking
pieces and I was hoping that I will be
able to Checkmate you somehow
Queen E6 as are the times a factor yet
not really both I mean levonne aronian
has lower time he's on the phone 86.
where is he going no no he's just being
uh annoying annoying
uh Queen back to E8 just saying I don't
believe is B4 a threat right now
uh quite possibly Rook F7 Rook F7 now at
some point I have to be able to go D4
now D4 starts to look far more
attractive right oh your queen could get
could your queen get top caught after
takes and night before
hmm
it's okay that is maybe the queen B5
and C6 right Queen takes B6 and Rook B7
Queen takes the eighth not that one
but I was also thinking that this is
awesome ideas of going Bishop
takes
I must say Fabby is somehow finding
something being more than irritating
he's he's getting something so now the
queen come to C8 to C8 uh Queen to C8
Queen to B5 you can't trade Queen to B7
Knight to E3 something no no look at
this no Queen Casino says he has faith
in his
that's exactly what he's saying with
this mover of D7 that he's he's as solid
as he can be 93 95.
something
and did that
that took him down to three minutes
though yeah and they're all sacrifices
in the air like for instance if black
were to get careless and move the Bishop
from f8 Bishop C5 is just very strong
okay
and that's the way to do it right just
wait once again until one minute and
then play D4 and there we go Knight back
to A3 I was actually expecting the
Knight to go the queen B3 is that an
invitation folks
is
my Spidey Sense tingling so he's trying
to set up this bind with an item B5 it
looks ugly but
so if I drop in yes you go Knight B5 you
want to take and no yeah let's go D4
nobody believes you with your Rook on
demons that's okay I'm only trying to
open up the C file so that I can play
Rook to C1
and attack the Knight on C6
yeah that's fine I'll take it okay
gotcha
I'll take it
and take this yeah
that's the idea
cool so he does not want to allow that
bind he plays Knight A7 I think that's
the right decision
Knight to A7 to stop Knight B5 stop the
night going to B5 I must say that's a
solid choice
yes
a funny looking position would come
after Knight B5 Knight takes B5 a takes
B5
uh that's not a nice way to treat a lady
the queen on A6 would really look
offsides but okay
it's so wow it might be fun that would
be highly unusual to say the least
maybe Queen to C8 will come in that case
yeah
yeah no it's a it's not a good idea
well I tell you I have 16 pawns on the
board the slightly laid into the game
seems very unusual to me uh I'm Rook to
a one
okay okay
Bobby's doing his best to try to conjure
up some magic here but I just
um I'm having a hard time but I was also
wondering about
setting up a bishop takes C5 sacrifice
or is this too obvious
because you know you follow that through
with B
B4
and then just
give everything up
okay his last move is quite funny but
maybe that's exactly what he wants to do
the queen to see six kind of sidestep
and queen C4
the very very quickly played by Fabi as
he's sort of saying okay I've won this
diagonal maybe that is a useful diagonal
and maybe maybe you're right maybe he's
going for some Bishop C5 B4 type of
sacrifices Lavon down to his last minute
and an important number
to take a note of is the last pawn move
was on move
33.43 okay
to look interesting he certainly is
starting to look interesting now Knight
takes B5 a takes B5 Queen to D7 gift
meet upon
and now it's time to break through now
or never how do we do it that's my
question before I was going to take on
D3 and say you know do your worst but
this is why
we won
yeah
be safe there's no check so then I could
just move my Rook to A2 right
and there would be no check to yeah
how do you not play Queen D7 instantly
he might be worried about text porn
about Bishop takes Pawn precisely
so Queen D7 Bishop takes C5 let's see
how this one plays out well
if he was worried about it he's asking
Fabi are you interested
fabby's saying yeah I'm interested
because I've got to win
I've got to win Bishop takes C5
you know this might be his best chance
Bishop takes C5 and Rook takes A5 and
you're trying to hope that Queen A4 will
will net you a king they
position where white has suffice a piece
the queen can just like snake her way to
the B7 square and hold everything off
for the time being that's a very good
point yeah
Bishop C5 is actually the best move
well again I just feel like you're just
not gonna get a better opportunity I
don't see B4 is bringing home
um
and I don't think Rook D1 Rook A1 D1
you're just not going to get a better
opportunity than Bishop C5 right here
right now you got to go for it
if you are fobby and you need a win in
this position you have to go for that
exactly apologies as I no he goes from
D4 D4
whoa that happened oh that's a secret
super fast what a sequence that was
and well Fab he is opening up the lines
of D7 Rook to D7 what is the action of
the bishop Bishop to B4 is coming okay
so B takes A5 Bishop to B4 what else
and Lavon
I mean you know sometimes when you're
begging for the draw you really
sometimes just simply overdo efficient
before push up to B4 I take on B6 and if
you take my Rook I go Queen A3 and I
think I'm breaking through finally
so you can take on B6 you take on D2 and
I go Queen a3m but you don't need to
take on B oh I feel there's a mate there
you can actually play Queen takes
Queen takes B6 and use the queen as
protection but of course you've got a
Facebook a too so you I do but hold on
could I just see this because this is
actually pretty funny In This Moment
uh is it meat I don't know
because if your Bishop was on G1 you
would have Bishop H2 oh my goodness yeah
I know oh but I don't know if this is me
do you have moves like Bishop takes
well right now I'm threatening Bishop A5
his if it was my turn I played Bishop A5
so
uh but I I didn't think that this was a
mate I don't see it I don't see the mate
I just kind of like get them my running
shoes and
hightail it out of there oh boy okay so
Bishop B4 on the board what's the times
41 seconds for Fabiano and Counting 38
seconds these guys are next to neck not
much separating the two uh Rook a two is
that no that's too slow is it is it too
slow I want to sacrifice an exchange and
play Queen A1 perhaps you have to go for
it it's 23 and taking down to 20 seconds
Rook A2 Bishop A5 Rook A5 ba5 Rook A5 D3
Queen A1 he's done it he's done okay too
he wants to sacrifice A5 Bishop E1
sorry say that again please
Bishop dc5 yes Bishop E1 oh Bishop E1
thank you that clears some cobwebs
Bishop takes A5 Bishop B1 I don't have
to sacrifice my attackers and maybe
fabby's not out of the tournament yet 15
seconds for both players oh and
kicking down Bishop E1 immediately
played that is a gain of five seconds
for Fabiano that that's huge that means
the a file is going to be oh E3 he's
looking for his countershot
and no time on the clock
guys guys is Queen C6 a move yeah no D1
is coming with check
oh you're taking the Rook I beg your
pardon Queen C6 is a move it's Queen C6
six seconds
the passive approach but he's
threatening Rook takes A5 and Rook A8
that's a huge and he's stopping D2
whoa whoa whoa five seconds and he's
ready to drop oh that is clever Basics
oh that was clever by Lavon
Queen to E5 what a move Rook to B8 and
King B7 he's gonna hide the king to B7
oh my God right now yeah that's what
he's B6
you want to hide on C8 no way no no no
way five
and Lavon but having to take these
decisions with no time on the clock it's
all about nerves now I don't know this
is starting to look good for Fabiano
guys we takes D3 and that King is wide
open truly
so you don't survive these type of
positions with 16 seconds on the clock
in general no you don't I mean you don't
like them but look at that
kick I mean that King is getting all the
way to G6
he's running he's a runner we can run it
to King E8 what okay now you can put
your queen on A7
okay I think he wants to go Rook to d8
to make sure that there's always a rook
D1 checks I will take that pawn on B6
yes oh I'm sorry but still you can
why not I mean I mean and might as well
take a pawn right Queen G7 okay
okay actually you're right why didn't he
take the pawn uh B5 he wants more B5 he
really wants more B5 no Queen F4
we cannot go to C7 threaten Checkmate
because you get checkmated first right
exactly The Rook is on priest
well B5 uh you need a decoy
Queen E5
Lavon you got five seconds
Lavon why didn't you go Queen E5 he just
attacked The Rook attack it again
E5 whoa what is going on I don't know
Queen takes E5 Queen takes E5 he doesn't
go for it he goes for Queen to have fate
what how much time did that take two
seconds for Fabi he needs to make a move
one second
oh the
check
this yeah
you gotta go Queen E5 now no that's a
check on A7 what is that a check F6
oh this is when I found it he might have
oh that move Queen f8 no time no time
king of five and ghost hunting
who who knew the King was on B8 ten
years ago
what the heck okay Queen
okay King steps back okay
A Move
oh
only move
where's the killing block well there's
no Rook D1 check now so all of those
ladder checks have been meaningful but
okay F6 Rook H7 perhaps or Rook B7
or Brook age seven okay I kind of like
seven seconds for Levon he needs to find
a cure against
five the King goes no Queen E4 check
no that looks weird I don't know he
doesn't make it he doesn't find it oh my
god oh Queen E4 check
what a gay Queenie for check and Rook G6
will win the game oh that's it for Fabby
that's that's it oh he didn't see Queen
E4
okay it's a nurse this is just nerves
oh but you're hunting the black king
this
oh this must be me Queen E4 check but
then King C5 yes
you have to go Rook C6 King C4 would
have been made that clear guys okay now
the king will just dance on B5
yep you're right about that
time time that was seconds we're talking
about Fabi has just 10 seconds
is this so clear Christian no no no no a
moment ago I thought Queenie forward I
don't see it anymore Queen to E4
followed by King to B5 that King is just
like running away amazing
no I mean I mean oh Rook C5 Queen B3 is
that is that it yeah I think
not yet not yet oh Queen A4 Rook a five
Queen C4 you can Queen D3 check I've
gotta play B5 yeah
oh no my Rook is hanging can you
intercept with the Rook Rook B5 you have
to
get a five okay seven stuff okay seven
King B4
this is a wild king no rooked away
okay one Queen takes A1 check oh my
goodness but okay goodness
that's correct but then I queen queen D1
didn't see that one
why did he play that move okay he saw
something but well the king king E5 and
otherwise it's going to be Queen to D7
checkmate but I don't see the truck made
even them I know no after queen king if
I was it was the only move to stay in
the position okay is there any Queen to
E2 right
you know in those moments when he just
doesn't see the maid he's got these
lovely Quiet Moves 24 Queen D4 queen
queen of five
The Rook is protected on C5 that's a
huge unbelievable okay and now he's
threatening rookie eight oh
that's a nice spot oh
Rook D5 I was expecting King F5
wow
what a game we were on the edge of our
seat to the very end
[Laughter]
an exit I know and that means only one
thing the players are tied and the match
will now go on to Blitz
I have to say if there was a heart rate
machine on that one I think the
commentators would have been you know
like higher higher than the players
what a game what a game Christian
wow and the scenario Jovi first of all
yeah and you can see that we have just
had a two-game rugby playoff that was
tied so this means we are now going on
to the
place and this means the players will be
playing with three minutes plus two
second increments
I think it's closer to Armageddon I
think we might see an Armageddon in this
wow not much between these two
Christians how do you cool down after
this type of match after this time yeah
I'm sorry you have two or three minutes
or however many crisp or decides that
he's going to give right how do you cool
down right now how do you slow down your
heartbeat it's a difficult question
right you just play this especially for
Fabian for Levon okay it's some sort of
a disappointment there are some hints of
disappointment because he knows he was
so close right that close position it
didn't seem like there's any
breakthroughs and that's exactly what
Fabi did what we were anticipating that
he will do he will take him down all the
way to the last minute and then open up
the position and that's exactly what he
did he played that D4 at the right
moment he had the option of also
sacrificing the peace with Bishop takes
C5 he decided against that D4 kept it
super complicated and won the match won
the game
and the match continues
we're very very intriguing we're going
to take a very short break because we
know the the game is coming up but boy I
gotta calm down yeah I could take those
deep breaths and I will see you on the
other side
colleagues are just temporarily in
disposed and they are repeating their
earlier the same opening from their
earlier game with 97 last time there was
a rook on E8 and this time Fabi says I
don't need to play rookie eight I'm
going to leave my Rook on f8 as we are
in the blitz three minutes for both
players with only a two second
increments so we're playing the world
Blitz Championship time control for this
one obviously the players would get
white and black the winner moves on the
loser eliminated and in case of a tie
we'll have an Armageddon
yes
well but the Rook was on E8 and there
was a rook on he won and that the
difference is that the Rook is probably
better placed on f8
so it takes takes we'll expect something
similar to the earlier game with e f and
GF yes yes and uh
whether we have to include Bishop C6 or
not we're about to find out but is this
a better version for Fabiano or for
Levon is the big question I'm going to
say it's a better version for Fabi
because in fact The Rook on E8
wasn't so well placed and The Rook on E1
was very well placed yes yes I agree I
agree yes
we we thought we were going to have a
five minute break and the players were
like let's go let's go
but uh hello okay well the players now
playing in the blitz playoff and they're
playing at a much faster time control of
three minutes plus two seconds
if this match is tied then we're going
to go on to the final stage of our
mageddon and guys we have the same
position we do we've absolutely
transposed to the earlier game and I
thought that the earlier position
strongly favored levonne so I'm kind of
stunned quite frankly that uh
um fabi's happy with his current
position and his side to change it up a
little bit he put his name he's going
with your idea of Knight to f8 Knight to
G6 right
previously
he played if I'm not mistaken F4
followed by E4 followed by E3 yeah and
he went all in on the king side yes now
he's taking a much more timid approach
but perhaps wait a minute I played
Knight f8 you you meant to say
courageous
you see what I have to deal with around
here I mean just like they just pound me
[Laughter]
a modest man with much to be modest
about yeah
well okay when it comes to the clock
times we can see that Lavon aronen is
the one who is has lower time than a
Fabiana Carona
A5 wow I mean a flash through my mind to
consider the move Bishop takes H6 and
Knight takes E5 just because the queen
side piece is on the on the piece of
fabby's pieces on the queen side
I can get to it are not active and white
ooh this move is an indication to me
that something's not copacetic about the
position for black well I guess do you
defend right now he has to go for it
right yeah exactly are we going to see
E4 and four uh as previously played go
forth
Knight G6 first then
that's the Knight G6 you have to deal
with Queen takes pawn and there's some
but I want to post your queen on to C6
so that I can go Rook to B8 and he's
done it he's done it he said the Pawn's
all yours if you want it that's fine
because I go Rook B6 and after that I
transfer The Rook on the other side of
the board once you defend the pawn on
Beto you have to defend that pawn on B2
I don't think you can allow me to invade
with a rook like that yeah I'm thinking
I actually want to duck the whole E4 F4
uh hits and I'm thinking uh Bishop C1
carpovian defending the pawn on B2
prepping Queen takes E6 yes so maybe I
can go Queen C6 Rook B8 Bishop C1 Rook
B6 and let that Rook slide across nope
first okay I can I I'm a supporter yeah
I like this move the bishop was in the
way of the E1 Rook
and well you've made this great
demonstration on the king side Knight to
f8 to G6 you're investing a lot of time
over there I mean at certain moment
you're gonna have to go E4 Knight H4 and
Press Your Luck but I was thinking it
maybe it's not E4 that you want to be
play maybe it's more along the lines of
move the king to age eight okay I like
this Rook B8 and then get the Rook to G8
and then F4 and unleash unleash the
dragon the Kraken yes uh
inviting the a inviting uh Queen it
takes a I like this move Knight D2 but
take a look at lavon's clock time
under 30 seconds that's not good or
pieces now Rook to B5
um I must say that I like my knight on
C5 I'd probably want to support it with
the move B4
Knight B3 but it just feels like those
pieces are going on wait wait wait wait
wait
a minute the King has no Defenders
exactly Now's the Time Bishop f8 Knight
to D3 Knight comes back into playing not
happy by the sequence for Lavon Rook to
D5 The Rook went from A8 to D5 It's
Magic and it's funny after C4 probably
it would go back to d8 and Levon playing
with seconds on the clock he's just nine
seconds Knight takes A5 well he's
inviting
F4 yep I told you and he's accepting the
invitation
and there is nobody at home on the king
side I I would be shocked if you know F3
and Bishop H3 doesn't know
arrive like a ton of bricks do you do it
now or do you take on D1 first well yeah
I I probably will not want to sacrifice
it which has to come back okay at least
somebody's back at home yeah age four
this is starting to look dangerous
your king h8 Rook G8 ideas
not too shabby and well he just simply
goes forward with his pawns and live on
time clock
he gets just an extra two seconds how
does Knight takes G2 not win here
Knight takes G2 King takes G2 F3
loose looks good agency
good movement
look at that
just in time
the golden rule of Jovi yeah but North
there's still a lot of danger I mean
look at that Rook h a Checkmate was
being threatened and now the players
playing so fast we see Levon is an
exchange down but he's up on time
check do you want to Bishop three is he
going to take that yes yes he had to
Knight to F5 Rook G2 check King F1 you
don't want to be stuck in the corner to
H2O
he found it I think he found it oh wow
wow wow with his back to the wall
needing to win on demand he did it and
our defending Champion with the black
pieces
well now he's pushed to live on Iranian
wow and Levon is like no break no let's
just get it wow is now in a must win a
situation but with the black pieces
truly uh I thought leaving the king all
by him is Lonesome
was was terrible uh decision making by
Lavon after Bishop D6 King King G1
and that moment we see Lavon
and here we go uh at the end
this was all intuition right because you
don't know whether there's going to be a
Checkmate or not on that side but you
have to go for it right
here is Checkmate so now I guess he
needed to play something like Bishop to
D2 or something allowing Rook G the
alarm and two and Bishop G1 that was
terrible yeah
I need uh need help as we get a new game
coming up
and uh
Abby now in the driver's seat all he
needs is a draw with the white pieces
how these matches change on a dime
seriously right
thank you Jovi
as we're getting ready for uh
if we see an Armageddon I hope it would
be unbelievable it would really be
unbelievable just you know use every
resource that they have you know show
every single ounce of grit and
resilience to take it to the next stage
you know we've seen LaVon in a must-win
situation Fabian a must win situation
incredible and now
and this will be their sixth game today
and Levon I feel exhausted and I'm just
calling the game
actually playing a very risky opening
it's a modern right yeah well a perk
defense or in in the Northwest we called
it a rat uh one of my all-time favorites
uh as a junior player I loved uh playing
these positions today I think
they even calling it the black lion or
something
you know you go H6 and G5 and it's it's
crazy what they do uh these days with
the modern engines and it feels like
right now it's a kind of a hippo defense
you know I think the black lion is with
E5 right yeah I apologize I think you're
right and Jovi probably knows much
better because one of our good friends
right uh Simon Williams are you putting
me on the sports you didn't read the
book sorry I apologize
your one chance uh two two two to loud
him and say yeah yeah cool you are great
course great stuff
Russian read
uh whoa E5 and wait a minute wait a
minute he didn't jump to
d57 putting pressure on E5 that's okay
he has to win he he does and so he's got
to take some uh extra he's not trying to
equalize things no no you can't equalize
but on the other hand give black just
one more move Bishop B7 and Knight takes
E5 and black will be the one for choice
so Bobby actually has to come up with
something very consequent
94 Bishop B7 an invitation to drop in
that was an enterprising move natural
pricing id4 yes 96 let's go with six
yeah and then the bishop will move but
then I think on A6 right
correct that's important the question I
would have is can I take on F3 Bishop F3
Bishop F3 something like well Rook A7
Knight B5
wow but okay if you let the A6 Pawn drop
that's not a problem because you do pick
up the e45 pawn
I don't think you can give up the light
Square Bishop I I think you have to keep
the light Square visual on board well
this is where he got himself into
trouble in the previous game he burned a
lot of clock in the middle game where he
ended up which is seconds and uh did uh
Lavon yeah yes is he is he is he dropped
a minute on the clock he's at one minute
and 40 seconds while Fabiano is at two
minutes and 12 seconds okay that's
already getting significant Bishop C6
same move faster was better
how do you continue right now do you
defend the pawn on E5 with Bishop D4
or do you take on A6
um
um I probably take on A6 and look
forward to the trades by the way the
young gentleman and the back ground
there Colin uh is from the Make-A-Wish
Foundation as his wish was to come to St
Louis and watch his heroes in action
he does and and what a match to watch I
know
talk about good timing Colin
okay here I'm probably going to play A5
and look forward to an opportunity of
playing Knight to D5 and somehow
undermining but a594
I apologize Knight to D4
I'm not sure if it's a good move I'm
just okay you have to be careful so
maybe I have to start with Knight D5
Knight D5 maybe bishop G5
okay
one Rook to E1 increasing the defense of
the Pawn on E5 well the nice part about
B5 is it does prep a square D5 as c2c4
would not be a move of the near future
Queen C7
I like this I like this I again if you
have to win with black
you couldn't ask for a better
opportunity because this is already uh
three results no question a lot of
pieces on the board and that's what's
important right now a lot of
opportunities for black still remaining
in this game yeah there's some danger
though in the position
is you can't just put a rook onto d8
because Bishop G5 but Knight D5 is is a
nice move is there any Bishop h6s in the
air let's go Rook d8 right oh you want
to provoke me yes I mean okay no because
Bishop G5 I have 90 days yeah okay so
you think Rook today I I like your move
Bishop H6 I must say that
I'd be six nine to B6 played with only
16 seconds on his shot right now 86. wow
I don't really like this move and I
think your Bishop H6 so I find it very
concerning actually that's exactly what
I'm saying E6 and don't like the one
just 16 seconds on the clock and it only
gets two second increment per move and
again uh the boldly stating the obvious
all Fabi needs is a draw and he might be
getting it from a position of strength
after this move Knight D4 that night on
D6 seven six no oh it's so difficult to
come up with good moves and the position
is still crazy it's still got a lot of
tension in it C3 Bishop F4 he just goes
page four piling on the pressure I like
it I like it in night on D6 I like this
I would probably play Knight to E4 I
like this Knight on C8 you you you you
can keep it on C8 yes and Fabi says uh
94 Rook D I like C3 I like my pieces
being protected but H5 Fabi is fabi's
playing like he needs to win
he has to
well now you have to get wait a minute
but hang on a second no he doesn't need
to draw but there's a problem with the
Knight F6 there's two nights under
attack
what yeah right on D4 and the Knight on
so he has to go Knight D6 unless he's
actually gonna come in with him uh
he can jump in within blundered
something here he missed can I can he
play Knight FC whoa whoa Knight E6 look
at this queen F4 Knight F5 Knight G5 oh
my goodness six seconds five seconds
and Lavon needs a win and fobby is
playing like he needs the win he's a
piece down right now I know but are we
going to see an Armageddon guys that's a
long way away with seven seconds oh
Bishop takes G2
what a shot
a queen takes E6 is uh lavon's idea you
take the bishop on G2 Queen E6 the white
one section Shelby this is crazy Knight
g57 Queen is getting ready to go to C6
and Rook is coming to f8 this is winning
Bishop C4 Bishop to C4 was a winning
move at that point no he missed it he
everybody missed it
five seconds
Queen E5 Queen E5
no
what's wrong okay it was broke Texas
Queen E5 is not Checkmate the the the
the G7 square is defended by the Knight
what am I saying goodness no but Rook
day C7 was oh
I think he made the move with one second
did Levant
and this is just pure Instinct right now
it certainly is seven seconds and that
Forks the queen and the Knight forces
more trades I yeah this one I have no
words right now should be winning Queen
DC Queen episode
he just moves the king
he could play E7
why didn't he goes Queen takes yes he's
done it he's gotten rid of the pawn now
it's easy yeah
Bishop V5
uh very nicely played by Lavon what a
crazy game we're gonna see arm again the
first arm together guys Armageddon
oh my word where are you going with your
king corner okay
just to get a few extra Tempe and queen
to D7 Bishop to E2 Bishop
yes
bravo bravo Lavon okay now the bishop
just comes into E2 absolutely or checked
oh don't don't allow
yeah Queen F2 F2 no no take the last
Pawn exactly perhaps the right solution
the queen G8 check is not the problem
here for for black there is no problem
yes it's a check but not much more than
that wait
wait a minute just when you thought it
was safe he just blundered that's that's
another and sweet oh and he's still
winning for sure of course
he just made his life much more much
is Just or the tension that the board
must be palpable oh
is there a picture right now with knife
is there a way of picking up this fish
you have to go with the H Pawn
okay Queen H7 check is not an issue five
and that takes away the final score of
the king are you threatening Knight G3
mate I don't think there's a way out
Knight G3 mate
on demand seconds left on the clock the
emotions the tension oh
it is gonna be the tournament very first
Armageddon which means that the player
with the white pieces will be playing
with five minutes okay yep and the
player with black pieces will be playing
with four minutes right that means that
they do get draw odds but there is a
nice little twist at move 61 of the
players I will get a two second
increment so it's guys hold on to your
seats we're in for a bumpy ride I I
hardly believe what I just saw this game
had had so many Twisted turns it seemed
like a novel that just wouldn't stop I
mean it was like that was crazy
that was really I mean oh my word I mean
good how how would you sum up that game
uh Christian yeah good luck with that
chaotic yeah it's chaos chaos on the
board but this is what we expected when
Levon had to win with the black pieces
right he did what he had to do
complicate the position create as much
chaos as possible
Fabiano did get a winning position
he was completely winning dominating H5
H6 get the king to f8 get close to the
Checkmate and then forgot about those
two knights being attacked at the same
time and after that despite the fact
that our producer was saying that white
had a winning position at some point it
doesn't matter because once chaos is on
the board anything can happen and this
is the only thing that Levon was
interested at the beginning of the game
just make it as messy as possible
wow and just to see the magic of
Television just a little bit at the end
here as uh pieces have been flying
blunders Galore but at the same time
I I felt that Lavon kept
uh the win in his pocket I mean even as
he wasn't playing all the best moves
this one right here and H4 H3 we're very
very impressive is he sets up a mating
attack with Knight G3 Nate
H3
so we're going to get the coin toss
right now we're getting it are we going
to see that coin toss is that the way
they decided with the coin test I
believe we're getting a coin toss and
whoever wins the coin toss decides
yeah
okay so guys right if if you won the
coin toss what color would you pick
white white white so you would click
white in another circumstance of course
I would take black in the draw odds but
in this match it's victory victory
victory yes
nobody's making draws yes it's crazy so
I have to go I'm taking black you're
taking black I'm gonna Buck the trend
and I'm gonna say black and the best
thing about playing with the black
pieces you just have to make the moves
as quickly as you can because in move 60
you're going to get the extra two times
yeah
um boy uh hardly believe it but the
crazy part about that game that we just
witnessed was uh
yeah this is a different view right five
minutes versus four minutes uh like you
don't see that the clocks are always uh
the same this last game that we just
witnessed it was like Bobby was playing
for the win yes yes he was and maybe
that was his mistake but
how can you slow the pace whenever your
opponent throws everything at you right
you you have to accept it yeah and uh
here we go as we see our
Chief photographer there Leonard
Otis C4 with Knight F3 no more nights
whoa we're inviting D5 take C4 there yes
yes Fabi wants a long game there's no
increment this is the bad end games the
letting game can't offer white anything
D5 yeah but it does allow whites to play
lots and lots of moves
so instead yes what we're gonna get is a
position with some tension and already
we see
extend on the king side obviously I'm
not a fan I'm not a fan
uh that's you feel that might be too
much I like the I like creativity but I
don't like bad moves that looks bad and
the difference is that white hasn't
developed on the queen side while black
has done everything in the position all
his pieces made a connection between the
Rooks it just feels like black is
slightly better yeah
get the Rook to D4 yeah something along
those lines exactly because A6
controlling the knights circuit but we
have to get a little careful because if
E5 comes I could just have some space in
an and be happy is white that's true
because E5 hits the F6 points four four
he's putting on the pressure
throwing caution to the wind right well
I mean he's been throwing the kitchen
sink at him since that third game
how many games H4 let's go flabby says
their seventh game
oh my goodness and what a match these
two have put on for us uh
and uh black we have to remind everyone
does After All Odds yes it means if the
game is a draw yes Levon remains in the
competition and we say goodbye to
Fabiano okay after this move B5 isn't
that an invitation for E5 we're all
ready to go we're dressed up Bishop
takes age six first
okay I like that move too uh just to
break open Black's King side a little
bit but he do give me the opportunity of
playing B4 now and kicking the Knight
away
and he goes for it you were absolutely
spot on with that one Christian
or do you pass by with the move G6 I
would pass by yeah G6 and Knight H5 and
he does and that that puts up a pretty
good Fortress over on the king side I
don't like that Knight on D1 that night
on D1 just has no good uh yeah it can't
jump to anywhere as well I mean the move
that I really wanted to be met yes to
make for quite a while was actually E4
E5 indeed and uh right now with a note
to E4 and okay but okay Club situations
so Fabi has three minutes
[Music]
Knight H5 is such a a deadly kind of
threat and that's why he played Bishop
Bishop F3 stop the move Knight to H5 you
cannot allow the Knight to jump on that
particular Square okay how about bishop
f8 and Bishop takes H6 good move
good idea
he's not going to touch that pawn with
the King no no no no no
uh Bishop again Bishop f8 Bishop takes
H6 would be on my agenda but a knight H3
and Knight G5 is coming
Knight H5 now that
is remarkable what a move nevertheless
the difference has been re-established
right now one minute difference oh
pardon me Rook the G6 yes I can play
Rook to G6 if Rook G6 F5 F5 is illegal
so we Rook the G6 with the King on H2
that move is illegal indeed yeah Rook to
G6 followed by Rook on A8 to G8 and
black has the initiative but wait one
second you still can neutralize it by
going Bishop E3 and then Rook G1 did he
just missed that move what ah you cannot
take on H6 because if Queen takes F7
yeah but I can play Bishop takes eight
no Bishop takes H4 he could play Bishop
takes H4 but now Rook to G8 threatens
the move Rook days H6
that's a big threat ah
how do you defend against it
can you defend against yeah it is
illegal F5 is illegal can you just throw
the knight in Knight H3 yeah
four is hanging
yeah I don't see it guys I I really
don't see it
how do you stop Rook takes H6 you cannot
stop Rook H6 in that case you just have
to
start using your pieces is important not
to burn the time in the clock so he
drops the queen back I think this is a
good decision I'm not sure it's inviting
F5 it's inviting
Bishop H4 as well as Rook H6 the problem
is there's too many tempting choices
here for live on and he's chosen F5 a
move that I really love because that
Bishop on E3 is now crying now you have
camera
do you want and try to do something
yeah but then you can go Queen G3 and
just try
stage four yeah I think yes
Rook H6 very very quickly played Levon
and the participants is that Bishop E8
is coming right now
so you try to hide that pawn on the
light squares good luck with that I have
two Bishops
the one on the board you call it Bishop
to E8 threatening Bishop H5 and
discovered checkmates I think this is
going lavon's way and by the way is up
on time right now
and all he needs is a draw and he's my
he he might be knocking out our
defending Champion with this incredible
play by the way Bishop takes H5 what is
that
that's a pawn
[Music]
wow that's it
I can't believe what I just thought
maybe
Lavon just won three in a row right I
mean he did he did it back to the wall
no wait a minute what what am I saying
need one too and no he won in a must-win
situation so he's had two must-win
situations and he must yeah yeah and
he's done it he did it with the white
pieces yeah the black pieces and now he
just had to draw he had to survive and
he beat Fabiano carono I said that means
it is Lavon aronian who goes through to
the next stage against
we say goodbye to defending Champion
Fabiana caruana